blood in the water floating bodies
covered in bite marks it's hungry more
meals will arrive soon the ocean is a
beautiful place filled with Majestic
dolphins and whales colorful coral reefs
and every kind of fish you could
possibly imagine it's also a horrifying
place dark endless depths filled with
sharks anglerfish giant squid and
unknown creatures that look like
something straight from a nightmare the
ocean definitely isn't the sort of place
most people would want to go after dark
but for one particularly adventurous
newlywed couple a nighttime scuba diving
Excursion seemed like the perfect way to
Kickstart their life together well Brad
the husband thought so at least his new
wife Lacy was a bit more reluctant they
had both been scuba diving before but
that was during the day she loved the
ocean when it was sunny and bright when
she could see everything around her and
relax with a nice sunset dinner
afterward the idea of diving down Into
the Depths after dark sent shivers down
her spine but in their vows she and Brad
had promised to always take risks
together and she already said no to
skydiving so this was the Compromise
this was what they were doing for their
first honeymoon activity tomorrow she
promised herself she would find
something more relaxing for the two of
them to do maybe a nice brunch and a
trip to the hotel spa but for now the
couple found themselves standing on a
boat side by side ready to take the
figurative and literal plunge together
Brad gave Lacy's hand a comforting
squeeze a silent promise that everything
would be okay it wasn't too dark out yet
the sun was just beginning to set
casting a soft warm glow across the
surface of the ocean Lacy took a deep
breath they wouldn't be going it alone
the Dive Master would be with them the
whole time she reminded herself he was
an extremely experienced diver he had
already walked walked them through the
necessary hand signals to let him know
if they needed to resurface and handed
them their flashlights they had already
sprung for the diving masks equipped
with voice communication systems so they
could stay in touch the whole time every
potential issue had been accounted for
now it was time to dive Lacy Brad and
the Dive Master switched their lights on
and slipped below the surface of the
water the dive would take them close to
a coral reef which the Dive Master
promised would look extra vibrant
illuminated by their diving lights as it
turned out he was right The Reef was a
sight to behold the beautiful blue green
purple and red pigments so striking that
they briefly distracted Lacy from her
fear of the ocean at night she called
out to Brad over the voice communication
encouraging him to come take a closer
look at this but he wasn't there where
did he go she turned shining her light
this way and that she called out for him
again and this time he answered his next
words made her stomach drop did you hear
that no she hadn't heard anything what
did she hear was something wrong with
his oxygen tank did he hear something
happened to the boat up above when she
pressed for an explanation Brad simply
said I Heard a Voice that was almost
enough for Lacy to want to bail on the
whole dive together but she didn't want
to be the one who ruined the Excursion
they had spent so much money on she
spotted Brad and began to swim after him
there it is again he exclaimed he was
still hearing things something must be
wrong with his oxygen tank Lacy thought
he's hallucinating from lack of oxygen
she swam closer to him reaching out to
grab his hand and bring him back to the
Dive Master but just before she reached
him he swam away from her grasp she was
about to call out to him again to demand
he' turn around and come back or she
would divorce him but she suddenly froze
in place as a sound came over her voice
Communicator a voice not Brads not the
Dive Master not even her own a woman's
voice she had never heard before
whispering to her in a soft soothing
tone almost like a lullabi lacy The
Voice CED come this way come to me don't
be afraid that was impossible there was
no one else out there with them who
could that possibly be and why did she
feel so compelled to do what they said
somehow she felt a pull the tug of An
Invisible Thread leading her in the same
direction she just saw Brad swimming she
could hear the voice of the Dive Master
demanding to know where she and Brad
were going telling them to slow down and
let him catch up but she had to follow
that whispering voice she swam along the
path that Invisible Thread was pulling
her the light in her hand Illuminating
the way she was swimming away from The
Reef a bit and swimming closer to what
appeared to be a dense kelp forest there
up ahead she could see Brad admidst the
kelp he was thrashing around kicking his
leg his foot apparently caught on
something then her ears were filled with
the sound of his scream
the flashlight slipped out of his hand
and it fell through the water It cast
its beam of light on Brad Lacy could see
the full extent of what was causing
those blood curdling screams the kelp
nearest to him wrapped itself around his
leg and dragged him slowly down towards
the hold fast on the ocean floor Brad
was fighting with everything he had
clawing at the vegetation that pulled
him but it wouldn't budge Lacy Shone her
light down towards the hold fast and
nearly dropped it in shock there she saw
a mouth wide and waiting filled with
sharp teeth the horrible sight was
enough to shake her into action and she
fought her way through the water over to
Brad struggling to unwind the kelp from
around his leg she was just beginning to
make some progress when another piece of
kelp gripped Brad's other leg continuing
his slow descent toward the gaping mouth
below Lacy was so preoccupied with
freeing her husband that she didn't see
the strands of kelp creeping up behind
her she wasn't prepared when they
grabbed hold of her arms pulling her
down towards another monster monstrous
mouth she thrashed and fought but she
was unable to free herself all she and
Brad could do was watch helpless as they
approached those nashing teeth but wait
there was still hope the Dive Master he
was still here Lacy called out to him
over the voice Communicator begging for
help from the dive Master's perspective
it sounded like the couple had lied
about their experience level in diving
and had gotten themselves Tangled Up In
some kelp and now they were panicking
with a sigh he paddled his way in their
direction looking out for the kelp for
as he approached he heard a curious
sound a woman's voice lilting and sweet
a lot like the voice of his wife's in
tone where are you come closer I need
you I want to see you I want to hold you
hello who is that he replied curious and
Confused Lacy and Brad both began
screaming even louder trying to drown
out the voice They begged him not to
listen to it to focus on getting them
out of there they warned him to be
careful and not get too close to the
kelp while helping them the Dive Master
scoffed this couple was ridiculous but
he would check it out on the off chance
something really was wrong and he would
try not to get distracted by any
mysterious Whispers no matter how
seductive they might sound as the Dive
Master approached the kelp forest the
screams over the communicator went
suspiciously silent he called out for
the couple waiting for a response and
received nothing but silence then the
whisper started again don't worry come
find me I'm waiting he shook his head as
if trying to physically shake the voice
off and continue his search there he
spotted two unsettlingly still
Silhouettes amongst the kelp he held up
his flashlight and saw the water
blooming with a thick cloud of
unmistakable red blood in the water Lacy
and Brad were hanging upside down
bleeding out into the ocean as he swam
closer for a better look he saw their
injuries bite marks at first his
Instinct was to blame a shark but there
hadn't been a shark in these waters for
years as he turned to examine the in the
area for evidence of a shark attack he
saw a winding green Shadow advancing
toward him the kelpin snared him before
he could realize what was happening and
before long the mouths along the ocean
floor were feasting once more up on the
surface the boat's Captain waited for
the divers to return but after a few
hours realized that something must have
gone terribly wrong the next day by the
time the authorities had found the
bodies there was nothing left but Bones
the deaths were written off as a
horrible accident possibly a shark
attack that was finished off by
scavengers no one knew that this poor
couple and their Dive Master were
victims of SCP
5189 SCP 5189 refers to anomalous
variations of organisms belonging to the
order of lineras or kelp instances of
SCP 5189 are physically identical to the
nonanomalous versions of their
respective kelp species with one notable
difference along the base or roots of
the organism there is a mouth-like
structure made from organic algae matter
as well as Dentin formations resembling
the teeth of a tiger shark when a human
reaches with an 80 M of an SCP 5189
instance they will hear the sound of a
pleasant alluring female voice
whispering to them these Whispers vary
from instance to instance in terms of
voice and content but are always
seemingly intended to entice and beckon
the person to approach strangely enough
specimens of SCP 5189 do not possess any
vocal cord s so it is unknown how they
are able to produce these sounds if a
human heeds that siren's call and moves
closer to the kelp the instances of SCP
5189 will move their throy and Blades
grabbing onto the person with a vice
likee grip these instances are strong
seemingly impossibly so for the variety
of organisms they appear to be but no
matter how improbable it may seem once
they've gotten hold of their prey it is
very very difficult to break free once
again a human is in the grasp of SCP
5189 it will begin to slowly inexorably
pull the human toward its mouth and
begin to consume them it is not a quick
process unfortunately for the humans
involved the organism takes
approximately one bite every half hour
there are no organs attached to the
Kelps mouths so their chewed meal drifts
out of their mouth and into the water
filling the surrounding waves with
floating streaks of red surely the
victims drown during this process making
these suffering as short-lived as them
right wrong SCP 5189 will hold living
bodies above the water as they slowly
devour them once the blood loss kills
them these newly deceased bodies are
pulled below the surface left hanging
from instances ofp 5189 until they are
completely eaten greedy in their feeding
habits instances of SCP 5189 will hold
on to multiple victims at the same time
they will keep the phalus wrapped around
these captured humans hum leaving them
floating underwater taking bites out of
various bodies until all of them are
gone sometimes instances of SCP 5189
will grow together as non-anomalous kelp
species do once a group of SCP 5189 has
accumulated 50 specimens of 5189 within
100 m of each other it is an instance of
SCP 5189 D1 these instances will work
together to capture and feed on bodies
and are highly dangerous on January 15th
2021 an offshoot of MTF gamma 6 deep
feeders was dispatched to eliminate the
first known instance of SCP 5189 D1
which had been discovered off the coast
of Southern California the team
approached the process of eliminating
this instance the same way they had
previously eliminated smaller Gatherings
of the kelp for the first 2 hours the
process went as expected and the mobile
task force was able to make a small dent
in the population there but then
something changed the instances of SCP
5189 began to work together to attack
and trap the task force the first member
of the task force to be captured was the
captain who was gripped around the waist
with a rapidly constricting phalus of
SCP 5189 the rest of the team swarmed
around him attempting to break him free
but the phalus squeezed Tighter and
Tighter until it had squeezed the life
out of him then it began to drag him
down toward the nearest mouth the sight
of their Captain's blood spilling into
the water was enough to shock the rest
of the team into action but it was
already too late their attempts to free
the captain had brought them too close
to the rest of the SCP 5189 instances
task force members would attempt to
avoid the phalus of one of the instances
only for another to block the path of
their Retreat one would grab hold of an
ankle while the other grasped a wrist
pulling in opposite directions and
making it impossible to wiggle free
without severe injury one by one the
task force members were ens snared some
of them drowned others were dragged down
towards the waiting mouths screams
leaving their mouths as bursts of air
bubbles as they vanished into a cloud of
red a few of the task force members were
able to swim away but as soon as they
stopped for a moment of rest they were
snatched by more instances of SCP
5189 the CP had spread further than they
had realized and was able to follow them
much further than expected mobile task
force members 8 13 and 31 were devoured
in the chaos members 3 14 18 24 and 29 9
passed away from blood loss within half
an hour of the attacks members 2 5 8 11
21 and 22 died quickly others were not
so lucky suspended out of the water just
enough to stay alive as the kelp feasted
on their teammates ready to eat them
next when it was finished no members of
the task force were left to exterminate
the SCP 51 89-1 instance ever made it
back out of the water the instance is
still there picked clean skeletal
remains of the task force still still
hanging from the Kelp to this day it is
uncertain how much SCP 5189 is in the
ocean there could only be a few small
patches or it could be spread out all
across the world smaller instances of
SCP 5189 can be transplanted to the
nearest available aquatic SCP Foundation
facility with minimal casualties however
if the instance is an SCP 5189 D1
infestation this should not be attempted
the area must be blocked off at an area
of 80 m from the nearest SCP 5189
instance and left alone until further
notice no attempts to eliminate it
should be made until the foundation is
able to ascertain a safe and effective
method of eliminating these instances no
one wants a repeat of incident 5189 D1
or to see any more bodies added to the
Grim aquatic graveyard there Jack was
swimming deep underwater wondering why
he had such a pounding headache when
suddenly he had a terrifying realization
he had no idea where he was or what he
was doing there was a nagging feeling
that he must have a specific reason to
be here you don't just end up deep in
the ocean with a diving suit on by
chance yet he had no idea what he was
supposed to be doing he wasn't sure he
cared either he was more worried about
the throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was going to die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered SCP
3000 before Jack's descent into despair
the SCP Foundation had mandated an
exploratory Expedition off the coast of
Bangladesh after receiving a few strange
reports from locals and fishermen the
foundation suspected an SCP was lurking
in the water and positioned a few
Personnel to investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead was Far stranger
and more ominous all of the men had been
verified to be in sound mental States
when the mission set out but a few of
them reported feeling strange and uneasy
as the submarine descended into the
ocean before long a veteran agent named
Dr Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong wrong
and if he could explain exactly how he
was feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as SCP 3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with the head as big as
a town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterward the image of the
eel-like creature's eyes seemed burned
in their minds permanently it would
haunt their waking hours for the rest of
their lives and sleep was no Escape
either as they would appear in both
their dreams and nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
SCP 3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Mission were willing to return to the
waters but a new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in di suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self- sabotage doing the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them were tethered
together for extra security but the
deeper into the ocean they swam and the
closer they got top 3000's location they
got the stranger things became just like
on the last mission first there were a
few minor cases of confusion one of the
team Jack thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation
but another Roberto also thought it was
his job in fact navigation was actually
the job of a third team member Amir but
he seemed to have forgotten everyone was
getting confused the team listening in
on the conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away 2 years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he desperately looked
around to try and gauge his surroundings
but he could only see Darkness all he
could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of Despair
and anxiety and this weird gray fluid
that was now floating in front of him
the foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing inches from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in too why
couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean ice and had now moved away from
the eyes of SCP 3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts and
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around SCP 3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of SCP 3000 now and
Roberto was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he had acquired some very
important data but he seemed to have
lost all hope of preserving his life
Roberto started telling the team over
the radio that he was dying and that his
heart rate was too high but cautioned
that it would be too dangerous for
anyone to try and rescue him the
Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after 3 days His Radio which had
only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head pain
parano fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams in the diving Trio the
collection of y99 might have resulted in
two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain y99 is somewhat
ethically questionable for most people
SCP 3000 produces y99 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close that this mission is
one way only other divers are then sent
later to collect the fluid from a safe
distance and store it of course it's all
for the greater good of humanity now the
foundation protects SCP 3000 as best as
it can guard something hundreds of
kilometers long the area is carefully
patrolled and members of the public are
not allowed to enter the part of the bay
where it resides anybody who
accidentally comes into contact is
contained eventually another pair of
foundation doctors went down in a
submarine to try and learn more about
SCP 3000 one became so affected by y99
that he began hallucinating he started
talking about anant shesha the king of
serpents in Hinduism anesa is believed
to be all that will be left after the
end of the world because it exists
throughout all of time simultaneously
the doctor said he believed that this
was in fact an anesa that SCP 3000
simply shows us that eventually everyone
dies and Fades into the darkness of
Oblivion right before he exited the
submarine and swam right into his mouth
luckily for now SCP 3000 seems seem to
be in a sort of hibernation state it
rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat when fed but no one
knows when or if it'll wake or what it's
capable of if it does will it destroy
the world or simply drive us all insane
it was a beautiful day in Sardinia the
second largest Italian island in the
Mediterranean the sea was clear the air
was hot and the beaches were golden but
the kagari diving Club couldn't see any
of that they were roughly 250 M
underneath the Mediterranean Sea given
the rich and extensive history of the
area they were sure to find some
interesting historical artifacts on the
ocean floor and they were indeed about
to find something incredible but this
history wasn't quite as dead as some old
Roman Pottery Paulo bonell the most
experienced diver was the deepest of all
they decided to be a little more
ambitious this time than in previous
Dives 20 off the Sardinian Coast for
Paulo it was Uncharted Territory so you
could only imagine how amazed and
delighted he was when he saw the shape
of what seemed like a small town beneath
the water Old Stone buildings in a
classic Roman or Grecian Style with
roofs made of thatched seaweed he
gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him they were amazed at how well
preserve the buildings seemed to be as
though they were still being lived in
and actively maintained to this day
despite being around 300 M underwater if
they were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts they'd be the
talk of the local historic community and
probably be able to finagle a payout
from the whole experience too that's
when Paulo spotted something truly
amazing a larger more impressive
structure like a miniature Palace
surrounded by grandio statues of
humanoid figures in a circle around the
little Palace each of the statues was an
composing 5 m tall with a faint Golden
Light emanating from each of them while
the statues were humanoid they
definitely weren't human their features
were strange and fish-like scales gills
tentacles Paulo was an awe at the sight
of them he took pictures and got closer
there was also a huge chasm in front of
the building perhaps some kind of
underwater thermal vent Paulo was
curious he wanted to investigate further
he swam deeper and deeper what was at
the bottom of that Chasm but lucky for
Paulo he would never see what was at the
bottom of that Chasm before he could
reach it something intercepted him from
the side something large and fast he
felt a white hot flash of pain as claw
raked across his chest tearing open the
rubber of his wet suit Paulo turned eyes
widening in horror to see a creature
staring at him like the statues it was
humanoid but not human an
anthropomorphic sea monster with
greenish skin its arms and legs coated
in thin scales its neck serrated into
fleshy gills he could see scraps of his
suits rubber hanging from its claws it
bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl Paulo could
see something in the distance behind
this creature more figures like this one
emerging from The Merc getting faster
getting closer Paulo was a smart man but
it didn't take a genius to to realize
that if he stuck around something
terrible was about to happen to him and
the rest of the kagari diving Club he
turned and fled paddling with all his
might away from the coming Legion of
aquatic beasts the rest of the club saw
the experienced diver panicking and
followed his lead thanks to their quick
thinking and expertise they all managed
to escape with their lives and only a
few minor injuries but they had no idea
of the true extent of the mystery they
were leaving behind beneath the sea the
Multiverse is a big place there are
alternate universes where the devour of
Worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear there are
alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone haywire and
attempted to wipe out Humanity through
controlled releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill Squad sent by the chaos
Insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the 05 Council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into to a bold New Era and
there are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian we've covered SCP
057 on this channel before in our video
on the most frightening rooms in the SCP
universe but you've never seen thisp 057
because this is the Italian version SCP
057 it this localized anomaly off the
coast of Sardinia is under the purview
of the Italian division of the SCP
Foundation found ation which works
autonomously with its own systems and
terminology this SCP is in a frightening
room that crushes its trapped victims
together this anomaly is an entire city
300 M beneath the water of the
Mediterranean Sea everyone has heard of
the mythical lost city of Atlantis a
supposed underwater Utopia outlined by
such great historical Minds as the
ancient Greek philosopher Plato it's
something that people fantasize about a
beautiful idilic Society Under the Sea
divorce from all the petty squabbles we
deal with up on land but is everything
really better down where it's wet let's
take a look and see when Paulo and the
rest of the kagari diving Club returned
to the surface they were happy to tell
anyone that would listen that they
encountered aggressive merman and an
entire underwater city off the coast of
Sardinia they even posted their photos
onto their official Facebook page along
with photos of Paulo's gnarly chest
scars that's when the Italian branch of
the SCP Foundation finally discovered
them and decided to intervene the
foundation dispatched an sir Squad known
as Oria Nota sirs are the intelligence
and research section of the Italian SCP
Foundation a kind of mobile task force
that investigates possible informational
leads Paulo and his team were given
amnestic treatment and any evidence that
they' collected was scrubbed from
existence meanwhile Lieutenant Marco
lavini leader of the mobile task force
smm2 Squad AKA leio Alanis was being
dispatched to the source of the problem
SCP 057 it itself what started off as a
relatively straightforward exploratory
Mission soon took an extremely strange
turn levini and his men reported
activity down in the underwater city
observing from the safety of their
armored Foundation submarine while the
Aquatic humanoids living in 057 it were
undeniably the same speci species their
cultur seemed to be split up into two
unique groups one group had thinner
scales on their arms and legs this group
was more numerous having at least 60
active specimens and was characterized
by their extreme aggression towards any
Outsiders as for the smaller group they
had thicker scales as well as a number
of eily consistent injuries to their
hands feet and gills they were also
distinct from the thin scales in terms
of behavior as they were a far
friendlier more Curious bunch at times
members of this subset would approach
the submarine and regard it with
detached Fascination sometimes they
would even point at the submarine and
laugh though their reasons for doing
this are unknown eventually Lieutenant
lavini was so confident in their safety
around the mer people that he and a few
other team members decided to disembark
from the submarine on a diving Excursion
and properly explore the Aquatic City
below this would prove to be a dangerous
tactical error on lavine's part during
what seemed like a routine exploratory
mission lavini was ambushed by a
squadron of thin scales grabbed from
behind and kidnapped he was taken as a
hostage and Spirited Away into one of
the city's various buildings where a
thick scale known as Leia acted as his
Warden but lini soon found that being
under letizia's care was a profoundly
lucky turn of events on his part both
because it allowed him to learn more
about the situation and because she was
one of the small group left in the city
who hadn't become dangerous Fanatics
that's right the myrr people were in the
middle of a heated Civil War both from
the observations of levini during his
captivity and later interviews conducted
by project head Dr jeppi pastillo with
some liberated members of the thick
scales they learned that a terrible
religious conflict had broken out in SCP
057 the accounts coming from the rescued
citizens Illustrated a similar backstory
to what the Italian Foundation had
theorized regarding the myrr people they
were the descendants of people that
lived on the island of nisos up to the
14th century BCE before it was
devastated by a volcanic eruption
forcing them into the ocean where they
evolved the ability to live in aquatic
environments through anomalous means
since this change this new species had
been operating in Mediterranean Waters
migrating regularly in order to avoid
detection passing their way of life from
generation to generation as the world
changed and shifted above them in many
ways they were quite similar to humans
such as their reproductive habits they
mate and reproduce after a gestation
period more like animals than fish
though their gestation period is
slightly shorter than human beings at 6
months they largely speak Latin though
the oldest myr person among them also
speaks ancient Greek myr children born
in Foundation containment have shown
strong language acquisition skills as
they have proven more than able to learn
modern Italian and even more fascinating
from a standpoint of sociological study
the myr people have formed their own
unique culture under the sea and this is
where the problems started abstaining
from the belief of the Greek and Roman
pantheons their ancestors looked up to
the myr people instead worshiped their
own group of water-bound deities whose
images were reflected in the great
statues in the center of the town the
large building near the statues and the
chasm was the home of the mayor the
town's def facto leader however what had
been a workable system for centuries
began falling to ruin when a strange
religious fanaticism began to spread a
cult-like group soon formed and began
holding ceremonies where they worshiped
a powerful entity in the chasm known as
the great eye this new cult was known as
The Cult of the great eye of the
Mediterranean or seam for short what
began as a fringe belief soon became a
frenzy and took over the better part of
the town with the acolytes of the great
eye proving themselves more than willing
to spread the gospel of their new deity
with violence some of the more arduin
non-believers were killed for their hery
While others were simply ritualistically
mutilated in order to prevent them from
rebelling letisia had her own evidence
of these targeted mutilations the thin
scales had cut the Aquatic webbing from
between her fingers and toes making it
harder for her to swim away and Escape
other suspected Heretics were given the
same treatment the reason the thick
scales even had thicker scales was that
they stole forbidden technology from the
mayor to increase the strength of their
scales hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and sarily
executed for their acts of defiance in a
sense Letizia was protecting levini by
advising him against trying to escape
knowing the acolytes of the great eye
would kill him if he did she knew that
the only opportunity for Escape would
come during the ceremony held by the
acolytes to honor their frightening
Master when the day eventually came as
lavini was running low on everything
from food to oxygen everyone in the town
was forced out into the Town Center to
witness the ritual the acolytes gathered
around the chasm and began to chant in a
frightening unknown language as they
chanted a blinding light began to
emanate from the chasm and as blurry
shapes emerged nightmarish tentacled
gastropod soon began to take form truly
lovecraftian under sea monsters shortly
after the ritual the Vinnie and the
thick scales were able to make a break
for it pursued by the acolytes of the
great eye it was a close one but
thankfully due to the intervention and
assistance of a trained mobile task
force the fanatical forces of the
acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
myr people along with lavini were
rescued a number of thick scales are now
willingly confined at site netuno an
Italian Foundation containment site
where they have undergone numerous
interviews with Foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest my
person previously present in SCP 057 it
the only one who spoke ancient Greek
fluently he was different from the
others extremely different in fact he
was a deity made into flesh one of the
deities replaced by the worshippers of
the great eye this unfortunate former
God had done everything to keep his
people's lives safe and peaceful but but
in spite of his wisdom and best efforts
hell had once again broken loose not
everything is all well and good in SCP
057 it even if a human's body changes
their nature does not and the worst
parts of human nature seemingly followed
these unfortunate myr people into what
should have been their Paradise under
the sea but all hope isn't lost if you
were to judge the entire human race on
one community in turmoil you probably
wouldn't leave with a very favorable
impression of us either correspondence
with a French branch of the SCP
Foundation reveals that myr creatures
aren't just localized to one Waring
underwater city in Sardinia mermaids
have also been discovered and confirmed
by Foundation field agents off the coast
of France 80% of the oceans Still
Remains unmapped to this day who knows
what else is out there just waiting to
be found a giant monstrous Crab likee
Claw closes around the throat of an un
imaginably huge eel-like Beast the
beast's terrible writhing tentacles wrap
around and latch onto the immense
crustation and then the high-intensity
beams of gamma radiation start flying
all the while Legions of skinless
Centaur swim in the waters around them
relishing the violence and in the middle
a lone boat the scps Smither Man by a
team of mobile task force operatives
that does all it can just to survive
there are those who consider outer space
to be the ultimate achievement in
Exploration the one place that explorers
have yet to chart and understand however
some of the murkiest Mysteries in the
universe are on our own Planet deep down
at the bottom of the ocean 95% of the
deep ocean remains completely unexplored
and the little glimpses we have gotten
paint a picture of something truly alien
giant squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP 3700 D2 interactions
between these two entities are
responsible for the anomalous changes to
the meteorological and geological
conditions in the area SCP 37001 1 and
SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carpas in detail
will notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years and years of damage SCP
37001 has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entities eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated gamma radiation at
a chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storm that impede its ability
to move with ease and can reach speeds
up to 100 km an hour in spite of its
immense power SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP 3700 D2 it
is a 32 km long entity resembling a
pelican eel in all aspects except for
its massive size and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its
body these appendages which tuck inside
its body when not in use are similar to
the tentacles of an octopus complete
with suckers the majority of the
entity's body consists of a seny tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated 3 km
deep its flesh is black and it has white
purple and red bioluminescent lines in
the shape of a man's face on either side
of its torso SCP 3700 d2's anomalous
properties include the ability to invoke
storms with a severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 winds the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
three-fold and the crop yield doubles
the ocean itself becomes increasingly
active acve and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase 5-fold
when SCP 37002 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water logs soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SC SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP
37002 will also regurgitate instances of
SCP 345 56 though how or why this is
possible is unknown for those unfamiliar
with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications SCP 37001 has
been implanted with donovian Hollow
projectors which disguise it as a pod of
humpback whales if SCP 37001 encounters
SCP
37-2 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
3700 d2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until SCP 37001 is
able to subdue it if this does not prove
effective and SCP
37002 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated trade and
Ferry routes to the archipelago goes
must be rerouted for at least 6 months
there will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water delta7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
SCP 37001 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 37002
burst from beneath the the surface its
head pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then sto to
bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
Delta 7 scattered out from SCP 37001
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
37002 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in in order to distract The Entity as
the Destroyers pulled their Harpoon
lines TT dragging its head in a
continuous Circle while this was taking
place the battleships got into position
and prepared to fire on the mither Mark
3 2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP 3700 D2 and it grunted
in pain thrashing back and forth before
opening its mouth and spewing an
instance of SCP 3456 into the water
as soon as it hit the water the eoin
monster began to cut through at a pace
of 50 km an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the scps
skki the skki attempted to retarget its
weapons and prevent the creature from
reaching it but the monster moved too
quickly for the skki to adjust the sky
was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it reach for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the skki was occupied SCP 37002 was able
to attack again blasting another ship
with a stream of blue fire a loud crack
rang out from across the sea as the sky
dropped back into the water the SCP 3456
instant shrieking in pain SCP
3700-3 distance in half sending its
human torso kening through the air and
past the scps mither freed from its
attack the sui moved full steam ahead
pulling the Harpoon line TD again and
dragging SCP 3700 D2 out of its path
several silky crew members were thrown
overboard during the struggle and as
they struggled to keep their heads above
water SCP 37001 scooped them up placing
them onto the deck of a nearby destroyer
and out of Harm's Way with the crew
members rescued as CP 37001 set its
sights on its enemy swimming towards the
edge of the whirlpool and emitting a
luminescent glow from two of its eyes
the constant barrage of cannon fire on
SCP 37002 was beginning to take its toll
and the myther ordered the fleet to
quote brace for the killing blow as if
responding to the mither's call SCP 3700
D1 shot several concentrated blasts of
gamma radiation at its foe leaving large
holes in the creature in their wake SCP
37002 screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its new found Freedom SCP
37002 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately tried to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club like
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movements stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corpse into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps stry Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
admitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP
37002 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SC SCP
37002 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity escaping ma
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP
37002 cutting the tentacle in half and
freeing the sty beast from its grip SCP
37002 shrieked before closing its jaws
and biting down on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 37002 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SCP 37-2 with its
club like limbs from inside of its mouth
all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower jaw was
torn out of place dropping into the
water with SCP 37001 still inside SCP
37002 thrashed fuly growing steadily
weaker and weaker it released one more
stream of fire before collapsing Delta 7
paused The Retreat watching the scene
for any sign of a winner but after 5
minutes neither entity had moved Delta 7
returned to the side of the battle to
investigate and saw that neither entity
was moving and both appeared to be
deceased shortly after Delta 7 reached
the area both entities disappeared
leaving a single round unidentified
object that sank below the surface where
SCP
3700-3 we read you Delta 7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7 SCP 3700 D1 and two are
both down command was silent for 10
seconds utterly baffled by the
information please repeat Delta 7 again
the myther said SCP
37001 and two are both down command
ordered the myther to stand by 3 minutes
of radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked asked are either
entity's effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for Deb following any
recovery efforts with their next steps
clear Delta 7 attached the strawy bees
to several tugboats preparing to pull
the vessel to safety but there was one
more surprise waiting the scps myther
began picking up unusual levels of gamma
radiation as well as a sonar contact at
a depth of 3 km they called command
requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes 1
minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at a decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next 5
minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
increase the ocean turbulence also
worsened tossing smaller vessels and
nearly causing them to capsize then all
of a sudden the water stilled and four
large yellow orbs appeared below the
surface approximately 300 M from Delta 7
they lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous contact and are
no longer detect in gamma radiation uh
we're detecting new contact 5 km deep
large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes we
advis should SCP 37002 manifest
exploration teams are to be considered
lost and you are to return to base the
consequences of this incident as well as
what else might be lurking down in the
depths beneath SCP 3700 are still
unknown 40 years ago a US Navy
exploratory vessel landed on a chain of
islands in the South Atlantic just 2,000
Mi off the coast of Argentina in other
words the middle of nowhere yet on this
far off set of rocks afloat in the
middle of the ocean they discovered a
vast array of strange wildlife and plant
species that resemble little of what
they left behind on the mainland could
this be a treasure Trove of undiscovered
species they wondered hoping to
capitalize on the Discovery a
reconnaissance team of researchers was
sent out to explore some of the islands
on foot and what they found did not
disappoint from endangered species of
birds to plant life and vegetation that
looked like it belonged on Mars they
found a dizzying array of new and
exciting examples of evolutionary
Oddities that would fill a library but
unfortunately their Jubilation was
cuture attempting to collect soil
samples they dug into the ground and
soon discovered that what they were
standing on wasn't actually ground at
all the Navy scientists soon discovered
the rocky terrain they were exploring
was actually made up entirely of organic
matter as per the standard protocol the
SCP Foundation was forced to silence the
US Navy research vessel after its
Discovery with the okay from the US
government the ship was torpedoed and
sunk to the bottom of the ocean with all
hands on deck in the name of protecting
the greater good of the masses a tragedy
at sea for the sake of preventing
worldwide pandemonia from there the
foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as SCP 169
better known by its nickname the
Leviathan The Leviathan is a Biblical
creature of mythical proportions said to
be able to boil the Seas and create
Earth ending floods with just a whip of
its massive continent spanning body it
is unclear if SCP 169 has the ability to
do these things though given its massive
size size which Foundation researchers
estimate to be somewhere between 2,000
and 8,000 km it's easy to see how
something that big moving at any speed
could be devastating for the coastal
regions of the world although we use the
word contain it is impossible for SCP
staff to ever contain something of such
massive size surveillance and monitoring
are about all we can do for now that in
hope it never wakes up and decides that
we're on the menu it was thought to be
relatively smooth sailing until one
incident changed everything Dr Hart
turned off the video monitor and faced
the assembled members of MTF gamma 6
also known as the Deep feeders renowned
for their specialization in the tracking
of deep sea and oceanic anomalies the
room was dark and each team member was
sitting in Shadow but still Dr Hart
could see the seriousness on their faces
I'm sure you're wondering why I called
you here at such short notice he said on
the screen behind him he put up a NASA
satellite picture of a small set of
Rocky Islands you see this little island
chain here well it wasn't there a week
ago he paused rubbing his forehead from
lack of sleep at 8:05 a.m. today we
recorded another auditory anomaly ating
from SCP 169 this one was much louder
and longer than the one recorded in 1997
by the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the one known as the
bloop back then it was easy to brush off
as some ice breaking off of a
continental shelf and scraping against
the seafloor it's not so easy to cover
up anymore these auditory emissions
fromp 169 are beginning to grow more
frequent more than that increased
seismic activity around the archipelago
on the creatures back indicates that the
rate at which the creature is breathing
is also up typically the rate at which
the creature takes what we are assuming
to be a breath is once every 3 months
the rate has increased to once every 3
weeks first as long as we've been
monitoring SCP 169 it's been a drift
along the southern Atlantic never moving
more than a kilometer a week that
behavior is slowly beginning to change
it doesn't sound like much but something
that big even moving just a fraction of
that faster means 100t tidal waves for
the entire South American Coastline We
Fear the creatures showing signs of
waking up if this is true it could mean
a cataclysm for the hundreds of Nations
around the world Millions hell even
billions could be wiped off the face of
the Earth if this thing just flips its
body too fast in the wrong direction to
put it to scale this monster is about
the size of the Caribbean maybe even
bigger as far as we know the doctor then
pulled out a decanter of whiskey and
poured himself a glass swallowing the
entire pore in one go in an appalling
breach of workplace professionalism
seriously an XK class into of the world
scenario is still no excuse for drinking
on the job we're talking about an
extinction level event a Bonafide XK
Class end of thee World scenario 1,000
ft tsunami weight stretching as far as
the I can see from either end of The
Horizon the last time SCP 169 stirred it
created the Mediterranean in fact the
legends of the biblical flood Noah's Ark
the same story can be found in every
civilization and culture around the
world so maybe they were on to something
it is to this end I call you all here to
save the world from the next great flood
he paused for a moment as the room took
in the gravity of the situation the more
we can learn about SCP 169 the better
right now we know squat for one we've
never seen just how deep the body of the
creature goes or what's under it the
pressure has been too great for our
current model submarines until now after
reinforcing on nemo1 deep sea
submersible with theurgical runes the
Integrity of its whole has increased
exponentially your mission will be to
travel as far down and as close to the
creature as possible if it breathes then
there must be gills or lungs there must
be some basic biological facts we need
to understand if we're going to survive
extinction our only recourse is to find
a way to sedate the creature and if that
doesn't work then God help us all just
12 hours later deep in the waters of the
Southern Atlantic a massive submersible
ship was diving down into the depths of
the deep ocean looking for a way to stop
the end of the world agent ja 6-1 a
member of deep feeders looked out of the
massive viewing Port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of SCP 169 behind
him was Dr Hart sporting a white 5:
shadow and a red nose from a night of
drinking to calm his nerves the entire
crew were silent in awe as the giant
flood lights of the ship brushed over
the Barnacle covered surfaces of the
unders Sea Mountain they progressed
slowly reaching each milestone in depth
with caution knowing that one wrong move
could destabilize the pressure in their
ship J 6-1 murmured the word scales what
asked Dr Hart I've been watching the
patterns of The Ridges as we sink down
they look like scales giant segments
it's hard to see at first because
they're so covered in Barnacles and
sediment but I'm sure of it they're
giant armored scales the way lobsters or
crabs have armored exoskeletons
interesting the doctor said scratching
his chin a ODS have segmented armored
bodies this means we might be looking at
some sort of evolutionary hybrid some
sort of aquatic MMO such as a whale or
dolphin one that has developed armored
segmented scales similar to that of a
crustacean the doctor crossed his arms
to think the closest thing we have on
the fossil record of this magnitude is
an armored fish from the Cretaceous
Period but even that's way too small to
compare to this this thing has an entire
ecosystem on its back how old is it
asked the agent well now that you
mention it given the impossible age of
the creature an aod would make sense
lobsters and other crustations don't age
conventionally you see they are
effectively Immortal in fact they
actually die because they continue to
grow until their bodies can't hold up
their humongous size anymore yet SCP 169
just kept growing the doctor trailed off
thinking to himself Dr Hart still lost
in thought turned to walk to the back of
the submersive
as J 6-1 followed he said as much to
himself as to the agent the creature is
old the Geological Survey conducted when
SCP 169 was first discovered carbon
dated the specimen to over 541 million
years old as you can probably surmise
that's too old for any living being the
results had to be incorrect and yet I
checked them myself more than once and
numbers do not lie The Entity predates
our civilization hell it predates
complex life forms on this Planet as we
know it from an evolutionary standpoint
it doesn't make any sense the agent
confused asked doctor how could
something so big even come into
existence very little of our planet is
actually land mass it's a wonder we call
it Earth most of this planet is water we
aren't looking at a creature that's on
our planet agent we are on its Planet
just then a flurry of alarms and sensors
began to go off at the bridge of the
ship the team scrambled through their
station checking off monitors and
shouting readings to each other the
ship's thermal sensors are detecting a
massive rise in temperature transmitting
power to cooling systems we have
activity Northwest of our location sonar
has something big headed in our way we
need to dive now the ship lurched
forward nose first as everyone on board
held on to their seats the restraints
keeping them from falling forward just
outside of the viewing Port Dr Hart
could see an enormous scaled appendage
moving fast in their location we need to
steer the ship clear of the talons
revert all power to the thrusters get us
out of the way the doctor yelled don't
you think I'm doing that the captain
shouted back the ship jolted sideways
and downwards as an immense wave of
pressure came over the submersible
putting six G's of force on its
occupants ja 6-1 yelped out of fear as
the ship came close to crashing into
what appeared to be the edge of a
Titanic Talon the size of the Empire
State Building following the encounter
the part of the ship bordering the
reinforced glass of the viewing Port
began to Glow bright red it's boiling
the water around us one of the crew
members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just cavitation due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated ruines on the ship's Hall should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission Bottom
Feeders after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of Nemo 1 began
to relax as their Pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater Behemoth before long The
Vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under under
the creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of SCP 169 after
several hours the ship Came Upon giant
fissures in the Rocky exterior of the
creature these massive vent likee
structures appeared stiff but slowly
they opened and closed over the span of
weeks these were the respiratory organs
of the organism clocking it at over 2
miles underneath the surface of the
ocean the crew carefully began entering
the smaller pod-like submersibles that
detached from the main ship ja 6-1
entered his pod and strapped on the
haptic gloves that would give him
control of the pod's robotic arms he and
a team of three other volunteers had
agreed to undergo The Dangerous Mission
of attaching artificial chemical
emission machines that could be
programmed to release anesthetic gas
into SCP 169 respiratory system on
command remotely the emission machines
could be refueled manually whenever the
contents ran out it was an ingenious
solution Dr Hart came up with when
thinking of his time studying sharks as
a marine biologist they attack the fins
of sharks by capturing them and bringing
the specimens on the deck of their boat
from there the scientist would drill a
radio frequency emitter onto the fin of
the shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student Dr
Hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
the these tags would not be falling off
he thought they could not for the sake
of all mankind this had to work the
doctor pressed a button on the receiver
of the radio and spoke J 6-1 what's your
status pressure's holding all signs look
good J 6-2 precious holding all good 6-3
all clear Captain 6-4 there was silence
6-4 do you copy all clear doc sorry my
mic was muted on Route and ready to do
this thing Dr Hart sighed in relief and
slowly reclined in his chair watching
the pods move closer to the large
openings on scp1 169 side one by one the
robotic arms used underwater torches to
drill into the thick rock-like
exoskeleton of the creature screwing in
complex million-dollar equipment that
was both waterproof and could withstand
the immense pressure at such a depth
under the ocean as the minutes turned to
hours Dr Hart couldn't help but feel
anxiety for the safety of his crew and
the success of the mission but before
long the pods began to return one by one
to the mothercraft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was J
6-1 whose robotic arm was in the process
of rotating a large industrial size
screw J 6-1 had all but finished when
suddenly a low Rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submers Dr Hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now Z 6-1 wrapped in
deep focus on his task repl replied I'm
just about finished just packing up my
tool belt leave it return to the ship
now that's in order Jesus what's wrong
it's not like this is the end of the
world said the agent chuckling over his
radio an earpiercing echo sent shock
waves through the depths of the ocean
around the submersible the waves rumbled
with the sound of SCP 169 voice similar
to the sound of a large whale but
Amplified by a million the sound sent
all the crew members falling to the
floor as the ship experienced severe
damage from the burst of pressure
slightly cracking the glass viewport and
sending smoke flooding into the small
Bridge of the ship gas masks shouted Dr
har as they all Dawn breathing apparatus
SCP 169 is waking up begin activation of
the chemical emission machines we need
to sedate it now the Leviathan is waking
up we need to stop it shouted Dr Hart
just then he looked back and noticed Z
61's pod was gone just 6-1 what's your
position J 6-1 where are you sir son has
him drift drifting off deeper into the
ocean behind us he must have gotten
knocked off SC SCP 169 by the Shar wave
but Dr Hart wouldn't have it he didn't
want any more blood on his hands reverse
thrusters turn us around and get to him
we're not losing anyone but the breach
in the hull it or hole that's what the
ruins are fall the outside of the
submersible began to Glow a slight blue
as the ship system started to come back
online to full capacity and alarm system
started to turn off and Report normal
pressure readings before long the Nemo 1
had caught up to just 6-1 pod and
retrieved the agent but been knocked
unconscious by the shock wave once the
agent was back on the main ship the
doctor turned his attention back to the
monitors making sure the installations
they drilled into the creature were
functional slowly the machines came
online to full power and the speed at
which SCP 169 had been moving began to
slow ever so slightly the team all
watched the viewport in silence as a
steady stream of anesthetic gas was
pumped into the respiratory system of
the gigantic living myth in front of
them after a few moments of waiting the
doctor spoke I think it worked he said
with a smile the crew erupted in cheers
as they radioed control back up on land
that the mission had been a success the
message quickly reached the 05 Council
where a red alert status was
de-escalated and the 05 members withdrew
from their plan of leaving the current
Earth for that of an alternate universe
the whole crew began to sing and
celebrate the prevention of the end of
the world as Dr Hart simply stood in
front of the massive viewport watching
the mountainous specimen slowly grow
smaller in the distance as the
submersible began ascending back to the
world above ja 6-1 came over to
congratulate him patting him on the back
we did it he said loosen up the doctor
managed to laugh along in
acknowledgement that we did he said in
relief that we did the two watched the
deep blue ocean and silence taking in
the vastness of the sea perhaps this
would not be the end of it but that day
they had done what the SCP Foundation
did best kick that apocalyptic can a few
miles down the road and sometimes in the
face of the terrifying and the infinite
that's really the best you can do the
year is
1985 16th of February a pair of
researchers aboard a model sm03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean hours ago
they were somewhere just off the coast
of France surrounded by Blue Sky the
smell of the Sea and the warm embrace of
the Sun but now only cold Darkness
surrounds them the depth of the ocean so
vast and overwhelming even light could
not Escape its grasp the Twan team are
members of MTF gamma 6 also known as the
Deep feeders a special task force that
specializes in the investigation and
tracking of deep sea or Oceanic
anomalies their mission to locate and
investigate the wreckage of World War II
German warship known as the bismar
thought by the general public to have
gone down in the naval battle with the
British in
1941 but the story the public doesn't
know is the real reason the pair of
foundation members were tasked with
locating the ship's wreckage site
unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated
radio Transmissions recorded by the
gamma 6 Duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismar
designated SCP
4217 the bismar lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gamma 6
member Charles Miller comments even
after the better part of five decades
this ship is still in pristine condition
there is no water damage anywhere that I
can see even stranger no ocean sediment
has accumulated on the hole of the ship
whatsoever prompted to investigate
closer agent Victor Miller begins
operation of the crews model rv1 Marine
probe an unmanned robotic exploratory
drone that allows the researchers to
explore the interior of the ship's
wreckage what they found unnerved them
or better said what they didn't find
just as the outside of the vessel
appeared free of any corrosion or wear
the interior of the ship was just as
Immaculate the hallway were clean the
walls adorned freshly painted signs in
still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto command centers
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew of the
bismar boasted a minimum of 2,000 men
where were the bodies continuing the
mission the researchers piloted their
unmanned drone down the Eerie winding
corridors along several of the inner
corridors of the submerged wreckage of
SCP
4217 the crew find large thick walls of
what appear to be made out of a
rubberlike substance soon they find that
the large vein-like growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubberlike substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle like growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the sea floor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurried to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and Evacuate the site but
it's too late a booming thud shakes the
underwater craft as a large Shadow
covers the glass window of the
submersible alarm systems go off as
cracks start to appear in the glass
surface the pair attempt to Pilot The
Vessel up towards the surface but they
are halted by a strong force pulling
them downward just as the cracks start
to spread across the surface of the
glass A giant shadow looms over the the
submersible what is that screams and the
sound of shattering glass can be heard
on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery
depths since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of SCP 4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far north as
the Greenland sea given its ker
containment classification containment
of SCP 427 17 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
an agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
SCP 4217 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained SCP 4217
enters a passive State and res submerges
SCP 4217 is divided into two parts SCP
4217 is the bismar itself a Nazi era
warship outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry SCP 421 17-b refers to the
anomalous seapod organism embedded
inside the hull of the ship SCP 4217 DB
has two large rectangular pupils inside
of octopod eyes that protrude from the
base of the ship as well as 12 100 to
200 100 m long tendril-like muscular
appendages that extend outward from an
opening in the stern of the vessel SCP
427 is deemed to be classification risk
class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 km radius confusing anything within
range and increasing the likelihood of
Friendly Fire among enemy combatants SCP
4217 daa's Hull seems to have the
ability of inorganic regeneration as
damage incurred from enemy vessels seems
to immaculately repair over time
researchers have observed what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of SCP 42 17- A's Hall It is
believed these symbols were part of the
original ship's design to bolster the
vessel's defense Integrity though not
immediately visible when the vessel is
taking fire the symbols appear to Glow
in proportion to the amount of damage
being mitigated among its offensive
capabilities apart from the standard
armaments of a World War II era warship
SCP 421 17-a also has specialized
Munitions of an unidentifiable gas
compound that is reported to have
mutagenic properties individuals that
have been exposed to the gas compound
undergo rapid spontaneous metamorphosis
at a molecular level growing an array of
evolutionary attributes which include
the accumulation of reptile-like scales
or Aven feathers in place of skin the
increase or decrease of the number of
Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory or organs and in one reported
case an event where multiple members of
One crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed SCP 4217 also has the ability of
subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be generated by the ejection
of water from SCP 4217 DB's body cavity
and reaches a top speed of a
approximately 30 knots SCP 4217 undergos
cycles of passive behavior that is
periodically interrupted by moments of
hostility towards civilian craft
particularly resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels It is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original Mission of the
bismar operation ryanbang during World
War II the German luwa was besieging
London in a series of nightly Air Raids
that would be colloquially known as The
Blitz it was the grand intention of the
third re to cut off supplies to the
British to limit the resistance to the
Nazi war machine however what pestered
the Nazis most and hindered this effort
was the consistent American Support
provided by the US government in the
form of food and supplies delivered to
the British via Atlantic trade routes by
cargo ship the German bismar and her
sister ship the turits were created for
the very goal of stopping these
transports of cargo to the United
Kingdom as well as sinking as many
Allied vessels as possible the year is
1937 in a top secret effort to make
preparations for an approaching War
Adolf Hitler turns to his most trusted
expert on the supernatural Chief SS
officer Heinrich himler among other
projects himler ordered the adner bay
obscur cor a German organization tasked
with the procurement and investigation
of Otherworldly or otherwise
unexplainable phenomenon to begin the
creation of two ships the bismar and the
turits the former named after the Iron
Chancellor Von bismar who in 1890
unified the German people these vessels
were to be created using recently
uncovered technological Oddities the
obscur cor had found in their studies of
the occult sources of information about
the exact creation of SCP 4217 are
highly expunge from the record but bits
and pieces did survive among what little
the foundation was able to collect and
in the records of the USSR after their
occupation of Eastern Germany following
the fall of the Nazi regime during the
second world war the early earliest
mention of SCP 427's conception dates
back to early 1937 when a top secret
shipment of unknown materials labeled
component of theological constructs is
intercepted by a foundation agent
working under cover in a German shipment
Center outside of Hamburg the foundation
anent Marcus stob is instructed to
maintain surveillance on the shipment in
1939 upon near completion of the soon
Tobe christened bismar a second shipment
labeled with the Insignia of the obscura
Cor is intercepted by the foundation
agent only this shipment appears unlike
any other reports of the massive
shipping container holding Machinery
capable of Aquatic Life Support indicate
organic living cargo though the
foundation agent was unable to identify
the exact nature of the contents of the
shipment St reported hearing sounds
emanating from the cargo hold sounds
similar to that of a heartbeat just a
year later the bismar is seen making its
first Naval trial run when it
experiences a massive Electric
electrical discharge just offshore
shutting the vessel down momentarily
until power was restored shortly after
reports show luminescent symbols briefly
visible on the hull of the ship
theological symbols for the Layman are
symbols that embodied the study of
Miracles because of this it was apparent
to the foundation that some occult
anomaly was responsible for the strange
characteristics of the German vessel and
an order for termination was reached by
the 05 Council the hunt for SCP
4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under orders
of neutralization of SCP 4217 all active
Foundation agents presiding in Germany
were ordered to converge on the side of
the bismar to stop the completion of the
vessel but when the time came for the
operation every single one of the
foundation agents vanish no records of
what happened were ever found no
clothing notes not even a trace of their
existence was left behind the mission
was deemed a failure and subsequent
attempts to neutralize scp4 27 became
far more difficult after the bismar
received a full crew of seamen the fully
manned and well equipped SCP 4217 became
a menace to both military and civilian
Craft on the high seas of the Atlantic
at times appearing without warning
seemingly out of thin air SCP 4217
psionic field obscured it from the new
technological advancements in enemy
radar systems the US government had in
development the ship became a shadow on
the Atlantic a subject of ghost story
for anyone daring to assist the British
government with the war effort
furthermore SCP 4217 did not seem to be
content with the surrender of enemy
vessels captured enemy ships were gassed
turning the men into manufactured beasts
and then sinking the enemy vessels to
the depths of the ocean even submarines
were no match on one report describing
an attempt to elude The Vessel by diving
below the surface only to be entangled
by enormous squid-like appendages that
dragged the craft back up to the surface
before crushing it in its grasp fearing
the safety of the public the 05 Council
decided they could not stand by and let
more innocent lives be taken they voted
to supersede the foundation's policy on
absolute secrecy to notify the British
government of the danger as CP 4217 pose
to Maritime civilians with cooperation
from the British royal Navy Foundation
Representatives joined the crew of HMS
hood and HMS Prince of Wales to track
reports of the bismar being cited off
the coast of Scandinavia in what history
books would come to know as the Battle
of Denmark Straight HMS hood and HMS
Prince of Wales engaged SCP 4217 and a
secondary German warship known as the
prince Yen confused by the ship's
psionic field the British naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismar and engage in Friendly Fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on SCP
4217 the attack proves futile as after
the Embers and smoke of Munitions fire
we off the sides of the bismar hull
appear to vibrate with glowing energy
mangled metal begins to straighten back
into perfect frame breaches and armor
begin to heal before the solders very
eyes and all that is left as evidence
the ship had ever taken fire is a cloud
of steam emanating from the hole of SCP
4217 the water surrounding the vessel
began to boil as underwater tentacles
Lurch out and capture the HMS Hood
dragging Her Majesty's ship forward the
men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from SCP 427's guns hit the
ship severing lines and damaging rail
guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen in mere
minutes the majority of the crew are
engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsions their bodies
undergoing rapid involuntary mutagenesis
including the growth of Limbs the
development of fur feathers and scales
in one report it was said that multiple
victims even fused together to create
one single horrifying entity those
exposed to the gashes compound were
designated SCP
42171 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of SCP 42171
overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the HMS Hood experienced is
forever in tune in the watery grave of
the British vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of Munitions fire from the
combined might of the German Fleet some
men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their
legs by the mutated instances of SCP
4217 and pulled under lungs filling with
seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
of HMS Prince of Wales decides to
retreat in the days that followed at the
bequest of foundation members the
British royal Navy launches a full-scale
Armada to hunt down and neutralize the
bismar though SCP 4217 sustained little
damage in the previous encounter the
ship began leaking a black oil-like
substance thought by SCP researchers to
be an organic waste product of SCP 4217
DB the Allied Naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of France
where under the lead of HMS King George
V British warships surround the German
vessel and open fire this time they were
ready with approval from the 05 Council
Foundation members provide the British
forces with enhanced Munitions and
Armament capable of overwhelming SCP
4217 theological defenses on the eve of
battle it appears to the Allied Forces
that the psionic field generated by SCP
4217 is too great as the naval company
find it difficult to land targeted
assaults on the German vessel after
losing several smaller vessels to the
Colossal appendages of SCP 4217
Foundation members on board authorized
the use of a redacted SCP it is brought
in to deactivate SCP 4217 cionic field
the tide of The Battle Turns and after a
fierce battle SCP 4217 becomes immobile
and unable to return fire Relentless the
British continued their bombardment
until the artillery Munitions on the
ship explode into a giant Fireball
flooding the ship's compartments with
the noxious fumes of the mutagenic
compound its crew members either jump
overboard or are engulfed in the cloud
of gas the British vessels capture any
survivors and watch as SCP 4217 slowly
sinks below the waves down to the depths
of the ocean where it would lay dormant
for the next 48 years SCP 427's 121
surviving crew members were captured and
interrogated most of the low-ranking
German soldiers were released to British
custody 109 of them having their memory
wiped by Foundation staff 12 remaining
members of the crew were sent to site 23
for further detention and advanced
interrogation and 74 of the instances of
SCP 421 17-1 the mutated subjects were
recovered and sent to site 23 for
further observation it was thought that
on that day SCP 4217 was deemed
neutralized and no longer a matter of
priority the Bismark sunk into memory
and myth it was only until the recent
Resurgence of SCP 4217 that the
foundation saw the need to collect as
much information on the organism
inhabiting SCP
4217 as possible decades old manuscripts
and ledgers were pulled from hundreds of
viable sources from the intelligence
then gathered Foundation members have
come to the hypothesis that the entity
powering the vessel known as the bismar
has what is believed to be
extraplanetary origin World War II era
documents uncovered between Commander
Carl reuter of the German obscura Corp
and a doctor Hans Meyer indicated a
discovery of an organic life form of
Unknown Origin found in a crashed
aircraft near feldberg Park in the black
forest mountain range in Germany further
correspondents with obscura cor members
OT Schmidt and Dietrich clner indicate
that researchers were conducting trials
on the creatures ability to create
psionic fields and to control or confuse
enemy subjects within its range with a
letter from dietr clner suggesting the
creature could be used as a power source
for an unspecified n
further evidence of SCP 4217 DB's
extraplanetary origin can be found in a
1993 incident between Foundation naval
ship scps nimed and SCP
4217 this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as SCP 4217 DB on
July 22nd sccp 4217 had reappeared off
the coast of Britain anticipating
hostility SC CPS nemed scps cesir and
scps partholon were instructed to close
in on SCP 427's location with orders to
subdue The Vessel if necessary however
on this occasion SCP 4217 did not appear
to be after any vessel it was simply
drifting along at Sea no propulsion
engines active noticing the change in SC
SCP 427's Behavior Captain Kurt Wagner
decided to withhold military engagement
and investigate SCP 427's Behavior
sailing within 200 met of the bismar the
scps nemid attempted radio contact with
the German vessel after repeated
attempts at communication the crew were
met with only silence and static chatter
giving up Captain Wagner puts down the
radio receiver when suddenly the sound
of music is heard playing over the
speakers of a ship the tune is the
national anthem of Nazi Germany the
captain hails The Vessel again repeating
his attempts at communication do you do
you understand me at first only static
can be heard then came a reply
you
ship the ominous voice could be heard
from the speakers the captain hesitated
for a moment members of The Crew looking
at each other with apprehension the
captain replied confirming themselves as
a ship and then asking if SCP 4217 knew
what it was and where it came from what
followed was the crew of the CPS nemed
receiving a video feed from SCP
4217 featuring a high volume of images
in Rapid succession among them were
images of German cities Adolf Hitler's
telecast of the 1936 Olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and an
increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or SCP 2399 as
Foundation members know it the trans
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and SCP 2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter SCP
427's responses become more erratic and
agitated as it repeats the words storm
cloud and red the markings on its hole
beginning to light up and the underwater
Shadows of its tentacles beginning to
create whirl pools of displacement under
the bow of the ship a shrill shrieking
begins to flood out of the speakers
followed by a high piercing high-pitched
beeping sound that overloads the
communication equipment causing Sparks
to fly as crew members cover their ears
and hide under control panels the scps
nemed barely escapes as SCP 4217 becomes
hostile using its massive tendril like
appendages to assail the naval
combatants firing its Armament in all
directions after a fierce battle the
foundation Naval forces were able to
neutralize and subdue SCP
4217 now for further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in
1989 any recent sightings of the Nazi
era bismar are flagged as Miss
identification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of SCP
4217 and protect the public from its
existence imagine this your researcher
with an interest in and an aptitude for
marine biology over the years your work
has taken you far and wide to the
furthest corners of the Earth's oceans
you've observed countless species of sea
life from fish and Crustaceans to whales
and sharks predators and prey alike
during one of your travels you find
yourself off the coast of South Africa
monitoring the local population of sea
creatures looking out across the water
you see a large dark shape moving below
the surface there is a shadow streaking
its way towards Your Vessel Dark As
night speeding Like a Torpedo you rush
across the deck leaning over the port
side as the shape swims Beneath Your
Boat you're certain you know what it was
after all your years studying the world
beneath the waves you know a whale shark
when you see one the largest known
species of fish still in existence the
whale shark is a filter feeder
consisting on a diet of Plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms a whale
shark poses absolutely no threat to
humans or rather any whale shark other
than this one would impose a threat but
how could you know that scanning the
water you strain your eyes trying to
spot what you assumed was an ordinary
whale shark swimming below but there is
nothing no sign of it anywhere sighing
you think you might have missed your
chance to see one in the wild perhaps it
changed Direction instead of swimming
under the boat you tell yourself the
ship turns and starts making its way
back towards the small Harbor leaving
you blissfully unaware that there's an
extra passenger on board as you
disembark you notice something on the
side of the boat emblazoned on the hole
is a motif of a familiar shape a whale
shark depicted entirely in painted dots
you stare at it for a moment intrigued
by the pattern it reminds you of a piece
you once saw an Aboriginal Australian
style of dot art you're a little taken
aback by The Coincidence having briefly
spotted a whale shark while out of
earlier blissfully unaware that this
painting marks your first encounter with
SCP
1449 known more colloquially as the
dream time whale shark in fact you're so
amused by seeing the whale shark earlier
only to find one painted here on the
boat that it distracts you you don't
realize that the whale shark painting
hadn't been on the side of the boat when
you'd shipped out instead you pay the
crew and thank the captain for letting
you hire The Vessel for your research
and then head off by the time you make
it back back to the nearby town and
settle down in after a long day on the
water the dotted painting of the whale
shark has already slipped from your
mind but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark you're about to
find out that your encounter with the
Dreamtime whale shark is only just
beginning you've never been a heavy
sleeper and rarely remember your dreams
any that you might have seem to pass out
of your head the moment you wake up or
are too faint for you to acknowledge
while you're sleeping but tonight is
different tonight you're dreaming
vividly in this dream water surrounds
you like it has your whole career but
this time you're underneath the surface
a drift in an empty ocean nothing around
you but endless blank sea you feel
something in your hand something smooth
and moving gently like organic matter
something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark and
somehow as is often the way with dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that
day the one that swam up to your boat
and ended up sticking on the side of it
as a DOT art painting SCP 1449 has this
latent ability while it normally appears
as a flat two-dimensional piece of
Aboriginal Australian dot art the
Dreamtime whale shark can shift whenever
it is underwater it still appears as a
collection of painted dots in this
unmistakable shape of a whale shark but
in an aquatic environment it be comes
threedimensional and that's what you'd
seen swimming towards the boat not just
a whale shark but SCP
1449 within your dream you release the
Dreamtime whale shark's tail and begin
to float
upwards breaking the surface of the
water you breathe lungfuls of fresh air
the first thing you see is land and it's
close by close enough for you to swim to
shore paddling through the water you
reach an island one in a chain of small
land masses tiny cont continents in a
shallow unfamiliar ocean you look back
to the water but can find no sign of SCP
1449 the Dreamtime whale shark has
brought you here and left you on this
island but you can only speculate as to
why there must be a reason you insist to
yourself the Dreamscape around you it
would seem is either the creation of SCP
1449 or at the very least a side effect
of falling asleep close by to where you
saw the Dreamtime whale shark in its
painted form whatever this place is
there must be some way to uncover an
answer it stands to reason you think
that if you can understand what's going
on then perhaps there in lies the key to
escaping this dream and waking up back
in
reality the small island you find
yourself on and the others nearby are
inhabited by strange life forms as you
walk across the shore sand clinging to
your wet feet you approach what you
thought at a distance to be a group of
other people instead you see a group of
peculiar beings they are not quite human
but they are definitely close the closer
you walk you notice these strange
humanoid shapes huddle tighter together
their backs to you when you try to call
out to them asking where you are or how
you might return to reality they bustle
away the wind carries the sound of their
chatter towards you and you're certain
you hear them call you another one just
another traveler from afar what you
don't realize lost in this dream envir
environment is that there are others
like it pocket worlds like this one
similar but different currently being
experienced by any others asleep near
SCP
1449 as you Ponder what to do on the
beach the captain of the boat you hired
is on a different version of the same
island watching a herd of multiple 2,000
kilo platypi being shepherded by six
tattooed 3 m tall humanoid figures
meanwhile his first m is in another
version of this dream world learning how
to hunt under the tutelage of a man
called gray the rabbit Hunter each
version of SCP 1449 Dreamscape have
separate continuities to each other they
are differing copies of the same chain
of islands with the same inhabitants but
each visited by a different traveler
from afar in their sleep much like a
lucid dream visitors to the Dreamtime
whale sharks worlds can interact with
them shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you would
like to make your way towards Higher
Ground to try to get a wider scope of
your surroundings fortunately there is a
towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like dark serrated teeth
against the clear Horizon you begin your
dangerous track ascending your way up
these dead Jagged Hills you're still
unclear on how you got here or how to
escape but you will yourself to keep
climbing knowing there must be some way
to wake up from this bizarre dream
finally reaching level ground you take a
moment to catch your breath collecting
your thoughts before advancing any
further you turn gazing out over the
landscape spreading out below and all
around you the island is small enough
you can see the shore where you arrived
and the ocean flanking this land mass on
all sides in this short moment you
appreciate the beauty of this bizarre
Dream World for the first time the trees
Sway in the gentle breeze moving like
the calm rolling of waves in the water
Beyond both glistening with the warm
light of the sun well it is still true
that you have no idea how or why SCP
1449 brought you here or how to leave
you think to yourself that at least this
dream environment isn't a hostile one
not that you'd want to be stranded there
forever but there are certainly far more
unforgiving places one can dream about a
grim thought suddenly Dawns on you how
long have you been here does time pass
differently in this world to the one
you're still asleep in as sound shakes
your thoughts back back to your current
here and now it was a voice you're sure
of it a voice calling out but not to you
traversing the dead jaged Hills you see
a figure a person from The Real World
like you not one of the local humanoids
they don't see you they're calling out
to someone in a ramshackle Hut cobbled
together from pieces of wood and other
scraps on the arm of the figure's dark
military-like uniform is a symbol and
you can just make out three distinct
letters s c p
a wooden plank that functioned as the
door creaked open revealing a second
figure the man looks disheveled his worn
clothing patch with scraps of leather
and shark skin making him looked as
cobbled together as his makeshift hun
like he was an extension of the small
structure you watch as the man talks to
the agent overhearing his words don't
say anything if you say anything I lose
my mind you can say anything and
something horrible happens the strange
man warns talking too quickly for the
foundation agent to reply you're a
dreamer like me my name is Nikolai I am
the ship Seer of the dun and the
Brotherhood of
sostic the man Nikolai he called himself
seemed distressed tripping over his
words disagreeing with himself until he
starts trailing off into swearing
obscenities I'm not Nikolai he shouts I
am aent anent Sean before stumbling and
cursing again I'm sorry I can't can't
keep the memory straight being this
Lucid for this long hurts the dreaming
fills in all the gaps things have always
been even as they are brought into being
I've been on this Cliff since the
beginning of time just like how this
place has always been here the dream was
torn Away by the death of gods Before
Time began but I watched it happen 5
years ago are you
following I can barely Tout The Dream
and reality apart anymore my world has
always been the way it is and we made it
like that we hurt the dreaming the shark
that's how we see it we hurt it killed
it in our world and the dream time
poured out like it spilled blood and we
made this big scar here and and things
are wrong fish walk and ghosts haunt the
stones and women give birth to plastic
children and the leech Fields stretch
out forever in the Seas of human blood
in the center eats cocaine and caviar
out of pandas skull bows on the crushed
backs of opal mares in acres of broken
glass and it has always been like this
don't don't do it don't do it again
you're already racing back down to the
dead Jagged Hills the sight of the
deranged Nikolai burned into your
mind a man reduced to a babbling lunatic
Cast Away and left alone in this strange
dream skate that SCP 1449 brought you to
but Nikolai is more than that more than
just someone driven mad by his isolation
he is a grim prophecy of what will
become of you unless you can find a way
to leave the Dreamtime whale shark's
World already back on the beach you drop
down kneeling in the wet sand as the
tide washes over your knees the how or
why of SCP 1449 bringing you into this
dream isn't important all that matters
to you is avoiding ending up like
Nikolai whatever it takes you know one
thing above all else you need to wake up
but whether you actually ever will is
another question entirely you edge the
poolside chlorine stened air filling
your nose the sound of splashing and
lifeguards whistling bouncing off the
indoor pool facility walls the water
ripples family and friends egging you to
cannonball in the pool almost beckoning
you to jump with its suggestive waves
yet there remains an underlying fear one
that brings your your hands to your face
and causes your teeth to chatter even as
the pool clear as glass with chlorine
hides no secrets a monster some teeth
nashing Megalodon ascending from the
depths of Extinction Leviathan curling
its Barbed tail to strike its prey at
any moment or even some vast unknowable
Force ancient as Earth hardly
comprehensible to human Minds waiting
dreaming in to breach the surface no
matter what form this gargantuan
invisible monster takes you know one
thing once you jump in you will not
return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the bloop that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters Krakens and Lochness monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto Shores
throughout America whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter
Escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water SCP 1128 in the vast
archives of a hidden site stuffed into a
drawer amongst uncountable Horrors like
it the SCP Foundation holds a
description of a vast unfathomable
horror that'll make you more suspicious
the next time you pass a pool lake or
even a bathtub or puddle of water SCP
1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assigned to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those mby dicks of the deep including
the several thousand km long arthropod
SCP 169 and has even utilized such
predators in the past for their own
benefit like the lengthy Beast SCP 3000
SCP 1128 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description Beyond
surface level details will fall under
the anomaly's effect the representation
you seen now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic promp the
foundation of course had to discover the
monster's effects in the first place the
chain of communication becomes foggy but
a tip from an unknown source alerted the
foundation to the monster's existence
and details regarding its manifestation
one man who had stumbled upon the
entity's full description started
developing acute theosophia the fear of
large bodies of water not Bodies In The
Water mind you the man refused to relax
on the beach or fly overseas claiming he
could see the monster's dark silhouette
lurking underwater ever scouting for him
this eventually extended to even closed
bodies of water like lakes ponds and
pools still insisting that the creature
swam under the surface trailing him
wherever he went his friends dismissed
him as crazy and he too believed he had
fallen under some hysteria he decided to
take a nice warm bath to soothe his mind
and ease his troubles he turned on the
faucet and let the tub fill up he put on
his best bathing suit ready to calm his
anxiety once in for all this had been
plaguing his mind for far too long and
he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the courage and with the anticipation to
just simply relax he took his first
confident step into the tub he paused
for a moment and breathed a sigh of
relief he picked up his other foot and
stepped fully into the bath Splash he he
fell straight down right through the tub
waves and Bubbles blocked his vision his
arms flailed as he sunk deeper into an
abyss of water and fear this wasn't
supposed to happen he thought several
moments later while still in a full-on
panic the buoyancy of his body began to
slow his sinking the bubbles from his
underwater screams Rose above him and he
began to follow their Direction
scrambling back up to where he'd come
just as he made it back to the surface
of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in Terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stalked him through oceans and
pools staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to Blinded By fear he
neglected to spot a puddle in the middle
of the road he ran on he raised his foot
arched forward and landed straight into
the seemingly shallow water splash sh
again he found himself completely
submerged and drowning after a minute he
did emerge from the puddle but not in
one piece knowledgeable of this incident
the foundation set about expunging any
traces of the monster's description from
the world physical and digital the
description had low distribution
according to the results of foundation
web crawlers but this hardly stopped the
foundation's Endeavor with Forum posts
deleted individuals located and
amnestied and cataloges trolled to
ensure the description did not
proliferate the foundation engaged in
what it does best questionably ethical
experiments first they had an anonymous
d-class uninformed of the creature's
effect read the description of the Beast
while the pamphlet they gave him
confused him somewhat he didn't feel
particularly frightened by The Entity
and he confusedly put on the diving suit
the foundation testers provided him as
they connected him to a cable and told
him to enter a bathtub the the d-class
did as they instructed him the d-class
expressed initial confusion at the tub's
depth remarking that it looks so tiny
from the outside as the d-class
continued to descend he analyzed his
surroundings realizing the nautical
reality that enveloped him he asked how
an ocean got stuffed into a bathtub but
the test organizer had no room for
miscellaneous talk he continued to
descend until he hit the Sandy Bottom
seaweed covering the ocean floor the de
class looked around tropical fish swam
in schools Coral covered the seabed and
to his right dropped an immense Cliff a
sheer Edge the test organizer advised
the d-class to approach the cliff and he
begrudgingly complied as he struggled in
his diving suit he fell back and scream
SCP 1128 The Aquatic horror swam
distantly gracefully even and paid no
attention to the d-class so fixated upon
it he realized that the creature matched
the one he read on the pamphlet and
almost complained about this when he saw
a blue whale swimming alongside SCP 1128
compared to the monster the whale looked
like a guppy the whale glided in front
of SCP 1128 Jaws the monster remained
tranquil stared at its prey and bit the
whale in two with one Chom its teeth
glistened in the water the test operator
requested the d-class to pull back and
as the cable began to draw him toward
where he came declass stared at the
creature swallowing the chunks of whale
hole the d-class eyes remained fixated
on the creature partially in Fright
partially in awe he wondered how ocean
trollers hadn't discovered such a giant
Beast yet with the world effectively
under 100% surveillance something the
d-class knew far too well as a convict
yet the d-class recognized and if not
comprehended partially understood the
ocean's vastness and mystery the dark
dark depths reveal no inkling as to
their contents and a creature like a
giant squid or the cican can remain in
hiding for centuries if not Millennia it
held him in wondrous thought to consider
the vastness of the depths when SCP 1128
stopped and stared at the d-class this
feeling of Wonder was quickly replaced
with fear as the creature approached the
d-class pleaded with the test operators
for help as the test operators
accelerated the the rate of the cable
returning the d-class took short shallow
breaths filling his body with dangerous
nitrogen as he ascended further
impairing his judgment he had devolved
into gibberish and screaming when face
to face the monster consumed its prey
the cable went slack and the test
operator pulled up only a broken wire
snap the water turning a cloudy red the
test operator knew that the unprotected
d-class had no chance at survival
against the monster but he could
potentially arm and shield them he had
another similarly ignorant d-class once
again dressed in a scuba suit and enter
the tongue however the test operator
placed the d-class within a shark cage
all out the movie Jaws and lowered the
cage in with another cable and winch
system while Unsure how this would Faire
with SCP 1128 the test operator remained
hopeful that the d-class could survive
and recount his story unfortunately as
the cage lowered into the tub the test
operator received no response from the
de class until the line spontaneously
tightened snapped and loosened hoping to
find the DCL class's Remains the test
operator only found shredded pieces of
metal torn and twisted like taffy the
test operator decided that he could
utilize the foundation's Arsenal to his
advantage and used an anomalously
toughened shark cage in his testing
perhaps using an anomaly like the
Clockwork machine as CP 914 he gained
approval from his high-ups to undergo
this procedure and after some testing
behind a shining strong as titanium
shark cage which he placed another
d-class within hoping for a success with
the monster however proved
unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous test only
without any sort of metallic remains
while bitter that the monster had won
again he wondered where the cage had
landed meanwhile Foundation forces
labored tirelessly to find SCP 1128
location hoping to avoid any civilian
contact with the creature luckily a GPS
signal established itself upon the most
recent d-class test with the tracking
device on the d-class signifying the
monster's General location the
foundation had redacted the location of
the monster perhaps in a vain attempt to
hide a very near threat from potential
readers the foundation set up a team of
only the most talented boers in its
forces mobile Containment Force Kappa 12
sea Devils upon arriving at the location
the sea Devils discovered the previously
enhanced shark cage completely undamaged
however closer inspection revealed
traces of human DNA on the bars though
the foundation could not confirm whether
the DNA belonged to the previously sent
d-class the test operator while glad his
shark cage survived the monster's attack
still found himself dissatisfied with
the overall results of the test he knew
he needed to quell this creature's
impact before a large population viewed
it or knew of it the horrible Beast had
evaded all attempts at peaceful
interaction
perhaps with a Madness not unlike
Captain Ahab yearning for the death of
his white whale the test operator armed
a d-class with a specialized weapon
designed to deal with aquatic threats
promptly this weapon potentially another
of the foundation's precious Arsenal
could potentially harm if not kill the
creature while he knew the foundation's
mission statement forbade unnecessary
destruction the test operator felt it
may turn necessary if matters turn any
worse thus he sent his armed declass
through the tub once more ready to
engage the beast in combat the attempt
as one may expect did not last long the
d-class upon spotting the creature aimed
his weapon at the monster and attacked
it but rather than drive the creature
away it only turned intently upon the
d-class as if it desired a fight the
d-class barely managed to scrape SCP
1128 before the creature devoured the
declass leaving the test operator once
again empty-handed defeated and without
any more resources to deal with the
Beast the test operator ceased his
attempts at vesting the creature and
followed the foundation's more cautious
approach expunging any publicly found
descriptions of SCP 1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion Zone as maintained
by the Sea Devils while the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what what would transpire
a d-class Afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required
eventually however the d-class needed to
interact with some kind of water
drinking water in a choice between a
little water exposure or certain death
the d-class felt inclined to choose the
former he filled his cup with water and
for fun placed his finger into the cup
dropping it into the water SC SCP 1128
unseen from the outside violently pull
pulled the d-class through the cup into
its watery domain the d-class had not a
chance to scream this alarmed
containment staff now cognizant that
even the tiniest specks of water could
transport an Afflicted person into SCP
1128 ocean territory this proved
particularly strenuous when a new report
of a potential SCP 1128 manifestation
arose an old woman isolated with her
cats and knitting supplies found an
article online with a description of the
monster moner frightened and disgusted
by what she read she closed the article
and continued on with her monotonous
life such a life would take a turn for
the worst however when she too developed
that all-encompassing water-based fear
her apartment overlooked an outdoor pool
and one day looking outside she swore
she could see that same dark silhouette
as the man did lurking in the water
among kids and parents playing she
swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seam shut allowing no light to
Peak through eventually this paranoia
affected her hygiene neglecting showers
and baths for fear of the creature's
wrath she swore she could see the
silhouette in any individual droplet of
water her skin began to flake as she
avoided water as much as humanly
possible cracks developing on her arms
legs and face inflaming into rashes and
itches her scratching further increased
the flaking she even eliminated water
from her diet sealing the faucets with
with duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice she threw out her cat's
water bowls dehydrating them they
pleaded with her as she continued to
devolve avoiding any contact with the
outside world even as it attempted to
contact her eventually a concerned
neighbor contacted the local police
concerning the situation and the case
caught the foundation's radar
recognizing the symptoms of a potential
SCP 1128 infection a mobile task force
disguised themselves as civilian to
enter the apartment building and
potentially interfere with the woman's
condition they entered the complex
climbing up the stairs with barraging
equipment for forced entry as would
prove necessary to use to enter the
woman's apartment she had nailed the
door shut with wood and sealed the
cracks along the sides with plaster in
an attempt to keep out any water vapor
she had similarly blocked the window
with wood planks a horrid miasma of dead
skin and citrus filled the apartment the
old woman soaking it in ever avoiding
the dreaded monster the foundation task
force attempted peaceful entry knocking
on the door and asking if anyone lived
in the apartment the woman couldn't
speak if she wanted to her throat had
dried to near silence save a croak
suddenly the task force and the woman
heard a rumbling noise outside thunder
rain the woman panicked and yelled don't
come in here in a froggy voice the task
force eventually decided they needed to
use their equipment and entered via bar
the door collapsed and an immediate
densed air clogged the task Force's
sight blinding and choking them the
woman shrieked and backed against the
window inadvertently the task force
insisted they were here to help the
woman but she simply heaved heavily
saying something unintelligible in that
dry cracking voice the rain began
pounding on the window patter patter
patter as the taskforce attempted to
gain hold of the woman she resisted
their movements moving around the room
while the task force intent
intentionally avoided violent
confrontation the rain grew in its
intensity as the woman continued running
around her apartment tripping over her
starved cats eventually she fell back
onto the window at which the boards
blocking it fell onto the floor exposing
the pouring rain fully she screamed as
she saw the silhouette of the monster
staring at her in every individual
raindrop one drop landed on her skin and
she violently vanished pulled into a
minuscule Speck of water the task force
collapsed from exhaustion perhaps
dreading their inevitable amnestic
treatment following exposure with an SCP
1128 afflect yet they couldn't help but
wonder what the old woman saw in a
single Speck of water that could cause
that degree of fear and paranoia the
kind of fear only caused by entire
oceans condensed into a single droplet
besides the monster what else did she
see in those multitude of droplets the
fish that populated the sea the whale
carcasses left behind by SCP 1128 the
sea Devils viewed from below Drifting On
The Water unsuspecting just as one may
view a grain of sand and see the Sahara
she too saw that raindrop and viewed an
ocean entire along with whatever
malevolent creatures inhabit it one may
have more Sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
in habits that body of water but that
the body belongs to a cycle much larger
than itself larger than any sea or Ocean
and the only thing that can Traverse
that cycle is a monster a creature like
SCP
1128 the task force went back to their
local site to report what happened
during the incident like so many
incidents the foundation deals with the
some tootal of those that risk their
lives for the greater good is a couple
memory erasing syringes and another
update to documentation a description of
SCP 1128 remains in the stuffy Locker
lurking in weight among other horrifying
stories in the SCP databases Sea Of
Terror just like that test operator that
attempted to best the monster could the
foundation's attempts ever surmount the
possibility of another person being
Afflicted could they conquer the sea in
a member of that task Force's dreams
they perceive a dark blue ocean and the
distant black shadow that resides within
and from this ocean they can view the
bathtubs sinks pools puddles cups of
water and Rain droplets of the world
seen from below although they know not
what as CP 11128 looks like they too
experience the fear it summons among
those that do the paranoia the fear
although it may not manifest directly in
people's lives it can always be a
observed stalking waiting lurking under
a murky surface watching with hidden
eyes water the Wellspring of Life we've
dealt with a number of anomalous water
sources on this channel like SCP 006 the
much sought after Fountain of Youth or
the terrifying SCP 3280 where murderous
water threatens to destroy the entire
world but we've never seen anomalous
water that behaves quite like this
before in many of the legends of King
Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who set out on a
particularly lovely warm spring day to
take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange Ripple ghost
across the surface she stopped her
swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touch this Impossible
Creature just as her fingertips reached
the water woman's own the figure
dissolved back into the lake with a
splash the young woman ran home telling
anyone who would listen about the
incredible thing she had seen that day
of course no one believed her that is
until word of her sighting reached the
only people who might take her claim
seriously the SCP Foundation they sent
operatives to the lake where they
managed to capture the shape-shifting
entity dwelling there SCP 054 also known
as the water nymph is a being made up
entirely of water with an average volume
of 90 L when it is out of a body of
water the being tends to adopt the
appearance of a humanoid woman though it
is capable of taking on a variety of
other shapes including other humanoids
animals and various inanimate objects
The Entity is also capable of shedding
its form and effectively disappearing
into a given body of water in order to
avoid shrinking or possibly disappearing
entirely from evaporation SCP 054 is
required to return to a larger body of
water studies of samples taken from the
entity's body or its version of a body
reveal that it is made up of ordinary
water there is no apparent reason for
its ability to move and no thermal
electromagnetic biological or
Supernatural anomalies were detected the
research team could not determine what
might make this water alive and sentient
and the nature of its unusual properties
is uncertain to this day when SCP 054
was first brought into containment at
site 08 it displayed surprisingly
congenial and curious Behavior often
walking around outside of the water and
taking turns mimicking the shapes of
various staff and scientists that spoke
to it its demeanor began to shift
towards suspicion and aggression however
following a series of experiments and an
incident involving the research staff
the first experiment conducted on SCP
054 sought to determine what would
happen if the entity was denied access
to any fresh water water was drained
from the fountain holding it leaving
only enough water for it to form a
humanoid shape but no additional water
in the Basin to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time SCP 054
became visibly frustrated as the water
was being drained out of its enclosure
for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
Fountain it became distant and even cold
to anyone who attempted to speak to it
054 only became friendly again once the
water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test SCP 054 reaction to
extreme temperatures particularly
extreme cold the temperature of the
containment facility was slowly dropped
until the room fell below the freezing
point of water as the temperature
dropped dropped 054 became sluggish and
exhausted it lost its ability to shift
between forms remaining locked in its
preferred humanoid female shape its
movements slowed more and more as the
room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the
ice were chipped off and studied
revealing the crystals were identical to
those of ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero
testing the research team decided to
take things to the other end of the
spectrum and test the effects of heat on
SCP 54 the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment and its
temperature was slowly raised over the
course of several minutes when the water
reached a temperature of 95° the
entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls
of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous calm and Cooperative nature of
SCP 054 was nowhere to be found this
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this new
found resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
Dr cesal the acting head of the research
team conducted a study involving SCP 054
memory and ability to be conditioned The
Entity was presented with a series of
increasingly complex phes and puzzles
when it failed to comply with the
experiment or solved a puzzle
incorrectly The Entity was punished with
an electrical shock or the release of
silica gel into its body both of these
options seemed to cause it a great deal
of pain and distress and it was eager to
avoid further exposure to them SCP 054
displayed impressive learning and
problemsolving capabilities revealing it
is likely much more intelligent than it
was first presumed to be Dr ccll
observing the experiments and with the
effectiveness of his somewhat unsavory
motivational techniques equipped to his
research assistant that they would have
it trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48h hour rest period
before experimentation was resumed yet
again this time Dr cesco planned to
expose SCP 054 water source to various
levels of acids and bases in order to
test its homeostatic capabilities
beginning with a5m solution of
hydrochloric acid prior to conducting
the experiment Dr cesal noted I have no
idea what will happen but if this thing
incorporates homeostatic mechanisms like
I suspect zvi should get some insight
into how it maintains its form he also
noted that SCP 054 Behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned SCP 05 54 displayed a now
familiar reluctance when it was removed
from its containment chamber and taken
to the lab it thrashed around in the
fountain splashing researchers with
water and retreated from them as they
approached in spite of its efforts
however it was removed from its Fountain
and placed in the experimental tank the
solution of hydrochloric acid was then
dripped into the tank and then all hell
broke loose as soon as the acid touched
the surface of its water SCP 054 became
incredibly distressed it Formed into the
shape of a human face eyes wide mouth
open in a Silent Scream Of Rage and pain
the water churned so aggressively that
the lid of the tank was shaken loose
allowing it to escape the boundaries of
its containment the water formed into
two large hands which shot out of the
tank and grabbed the two nearest
researchers pulling them into the water
and exposing their skin to the acid now
present there as the men scrambled to
drag themselves back out of the tank and
their colleagues were busy helping them
SCP 054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its Escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment facility
the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns
on their skin as well as significant
mental distress they were given
immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on SCP 054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr ccll 04's object
class was changed to uclid SCP 054 is
currently contained in a watertight
isolation room fitted with climate
control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entities
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area must wear
NBC suits while inside and must spend 10
minutes isolated in a dry room After
exiting before they are permitted to
return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the
entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis and kept at optimal levels
for the health of SCP 054 during the
course of its containment following the
incident around the acid base
incorporation experiment 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep SCP 054 calm
no male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because 5 years have passed since the
last incident involving SCP 054 its
object class has been changed from uclid
to safe on the recommendation of the
lead researcher assigned to its case of
course caution should still be exercised
while interacting with the entity this
is the SCP Foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown experimentation on SCP 054
has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate The
Entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself the ocean is a
terrifying Place we've all heard the
statistics more than 80% of the ocean
remains unexplored that's most of the
water covering the globe completely
unmapped and unobserved by science it's
a scary thought to dwell on realizing
that there's more water than land on
Earth and the sheer expanse of that
water is so large that we've been unable
to fully explore all of it just think
there are places in the ocean that have
never been seen by a human who knows
what's down there if there was ever a
personification of fear of the unknown
the ocean could definitely be it ancient
shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor
unknown sea creatures hiding away from
humanity and the general isolation of
the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious depths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical Mysteries than the SC CP
Foundation today we'll be taking a look
at SCP 5007 the bass straight a wave of
oceanic anomy fit to make any seasoned
sailor shiver in fear the bass straight
is an area of ocean dividing Tasmania
and the Australian Mainland it's also
the location of an unusually high amount
of disappearances Sailors disappearing
from their ships fishermen leaving in
the night and never coming back even
civilians disappearing from the shores
that connect to the straight the
foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the straight
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bass straight and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the straight agent taberer an operative
of the SCP Foundation was vacationing
with his wife Mary and his three young
children the Taber family was simply
enjoying their day when they saw what
looked like balloons in the sky they
were approaching quickly and naturally
the family moved closer what happened
next was a whirlwind and those balloons
the family were so interested in Lifted
them up from the ground and carried them
away agent taberer tried to fight back
but there was nothing he could do except
report to the foundation what had
occurred and the organization responded
in full force the foundation's research
discovered that reports of UFOs and
lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the straight and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost Taber family members had
become a large scale investigation into
unexplained disappearances along the
bass straight and within 3 weeks it was
determined that these patterns were were
consistent across the entirety of the
Strait's coastal regions some witnesses
were interviewed but the vast majority
of these abduction cases had no
Witnesses whatsoever of the minimal
reports filed the foundation was told
that there were lights in the sky and
that appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the
appearances of balloons one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
Alan Stewart a witness who was present
during The Disappearance of former
Australian prime minister Harold Holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bast Strait anomalies during the
interview steuart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Hol turned to Stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff Stuart had no idea what Holt was
talking about but Holt was insistent on
seeing them he swam deeper out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them Stuart and Hal's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen steuart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping Holt away but
he couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer Stuart saw Holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the Prime Minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
Holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked
steuart for the interview and continued
their investigation 2 years later in
1982 Emergency Services received a large
number of calls pertaining to UFO
sightings off the coast of Norman Bay
Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as SCP 5007 they evacuated civilians
from the area and successfully managed
to capture the creature which was later
transported to site 40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated SCP 57- S1 was a cluster of
human bodies fused between a grouping of
black tentacles of varying length each
tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the Bucy of
which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the The Entity
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appeared to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of SCP 57 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when en
encountered SCP 57s behavior during
abduction scenarios was documented
during the initial containment event and
due to the foundation's painstaking
research a pattern was established
between all SCP 5007 encounters first
the victim would be alone or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location SCP
5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass straight in small
coastal towns beaches or boats SCP 5007
will then move towards the shore
stalking the victim before lowering its
tentacles and appendages to grab the
individual snatching them into the sky
an SCP 57 instance can even abduct
multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
SCP 57 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where SCP 5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
SCP 5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
Waters of the bass straight and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encountered them
in 1985 the foundation's research
efforts paid off and several survey
teams operating in the area reported a
sighting of an extremely large SCP 5007
instance heading towards a coastal town
a mobile task force was sent to track
the entity the team observed The Entity
from afar as it stocked a private
fishing boat even from the distance
Foundation Personnel recognized the
likenesses of several missing persons as
faces of the corpses of SCP 5007 the
task force Captain had to remind his
team to keep it together claiming that
they were not people but just parts of
the specimen but everyone secretly knew
the truth the fishing vessel was a
private one occupied by a small family
The Entity slowly approached and quickly
pulled a woman into the air the family
panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety running into the Ship's
Cabin The Entity ran its tentacles along
the boat until it pulled the door open
snatching another two victims the task
force was unable to to help them as
their mission was to track the instance
to its origin point it was a horror to
watch the task force implanted a
tracking Beacon onto the entity and
quietly followed it out to sea over the
next 4 hours they then discovered a
large gray Reef with several shipwrecks
dotted across it 13 SCP 57 instances
floated over the area some holding on to
the land Reef with their tentacles The
Entity dropped the abductees from the
fishing boat who were coerced by The
Entity ities into diving into a massive
pool of water located in the center of
the reef one by one each abductee was
pulled below the surface by something
lurking in the pool all while the SCP 57
instances watched disgusted the task
force reported what they observed to the
main site and the reef would be
designated as SCP
57- the foundation's analysis of the
reef led to the discovery that The Rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the wreck
ships and aircraft that washed across
the shore of the reef were covered with
a dark stone The Reef was teaming with
anomalous marine life including SCP 5007
a red algae that fed upon the freshly
grown Rock Marine worms capable of
levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the waterline small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented as
SCP 4159 in a separate investigation SCP
5007 often rested their tentacles on the
outcroppings of the reef while inactive
but what caught the foundation's
attention the most was the giant pit
located in the reef center unmanned
exploration drones found that it had a
depth of at least 4,000 M and water
samples taken from the pit revealed
large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in a storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boy said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
Island we are all a feared but there is
not we can do but Beach ourselves and
help for rescue should I be killed in
the crash I want my mate to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to SCP 5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pil engaged in a training flight over
the bass straight in 1978 valentic
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an SCP 5007 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this Valenti's transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the SCP 5007 instance attacking the
aircraft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the abductees had
been prior the foundation decided to
construct a provisional secure research
facility on the reef they named it site
4-r and documented all returns and
departures of SCP 5007 they also set up
a series of containment procedures that
resulted in SCP P 57 returning with its
victims 83% less often than before the
site's construction but this was
short-lived in 2008 the site logged over
36 instances returning to the reef with
only two not having any fresh abductees
the instances Origins were unknown and
it was as if they appeared out of thin
air no other monitoring post had
documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidence by
what happened to the victims of SCP 5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the Pit's depths
caused all craft to collapse due to Hull
damage this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the SCP s Nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13,500 M underwater
they decided that a d-class Personnel
would be trained to man The submersible
and carry out the exploration the
mission was simple the Nautilus was to
dive to the bottom of the pit and to
describe the depth readings cameras and
microphones were equipped to the vessel
due to the depth remote viewing of the
footage was impossible instead the
foundation had to physically recollect
the vessel in order to view the footage
upon recovery some of the footage
suffered data corruption but what was
there shook those who viewed it to their
core the footage showed the d-class
experience going deeper inside the pit
at first it seemed ordinary the trench
had a number of Rocky outcroppings
dotted with black yellow Vines growing
along the walls also present were
various marine life forms such as the
spiders or the fish going deeper the sub
observed an SCP 57 instance clinging to
an outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were w W around
the instance and holding on to the
entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16 SCP 57 instances were seen
resting along the walls each clinging to
the outcropping as the sub went deeper
the d-class remarked that there were
dozens of plane and shipwrecks but also
well over 100 SCP 57 entities most of
them were held there by the black
tendrils the d-class as the sub went
even deeper began noticing human remains
no short amount of them either deep into
the pit there was a large mass of human
remains covering the entirety of the pit
bodies crushed and drained of blood but
still possessing intact eyes each
individual was still alive kept
preserved by the life- sustaining
compounds found within the water the
body stared at the sub and moved
attempting to grab onto the vehicle the
declass swore they were trying to say
something mouthing words to the camera
of the sub as the sub passed through the
map massive bodies it emerged into a
completely dark black clearing at the
bottom of the pit for a second the
declass thought he was safe but then a
large black tentacle rapidly emerged
from below and grabbed onto the Nautilus
dragging it even further Into the Depths
the d-class screamed and panicked but
there was nothing he could do the
tentacle possessed a large cluster of
eyes mouths and human heads seemingly
grafted onto its mass and then there was
another tentacle and then another the
Nautilus was pull to the bottom of the
pool the d-class screams were still
heard even as the picture cut out
sometimes graphic body altering images
of the tentacle features were visible on
the screen but most of the footage was
indecipherable after minutes of
distorted corrupted footage the Nautilus
was seen again rapidly ascending to the
surface somehow it had managed to escape
the entity at the bottom of the pit upon
recovery of The Craft it was found that
the Nautilus was covered in a thick
organic coating similar to a black SL SL
mold but with dozens of eyes growing
from it the d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was shortlived
after the containment seal was fitted
site 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
4-r went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma- 6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site 40- was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the sight's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the bass
straight never knowing what their next
move might be and always keeping in mind
the risk that comes with dealing with
these poorly understood entities Dr
reard had lost everything his job the
respect of his peers and if everyone
else was right perhaps even his mind it
was 11:00 p.m. when he staggered to the
edge of Okanagan Lake in British
Columbia eyes and judgment clouded with
booze this Lake could have been what
made his career as a researcher for the
SCP Foundation but now that bright
future was slipping through his fingers
like the dry silt beneath his feet he
looked hatefully across the endless dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed
stupid empty place just hours ago he'd
been stripped of his r ranks and release
from his position at the foundation for
wasting the organization's time and
resources on frivolous personal projects
frivolous he thought what a terrible
joke just because the higher-ups refused
to acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there Moonlight
shimmered off the water's surface wait
was that Moonlight or was there
something lurking underneath the water
to truly answer this question if any
answer is possible at all we need to go
back to the beginning and ask ourselves
a different question how does the SCP
Foundation actually find most of the
anomalies it cataloges and contains it
is a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of Interest like the global
occult Coalition and the Serpent's hand
if they so much as sniff the strange and
unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary Personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rarer but
still incredibly important methods of
finding scps involve looking into myths
and local Legends sure it may seem like
a good way to waste time and resources
but the crossover between recorded scps
and folklore is surprisingly common AK
SCP 1000 the formerly hyper intelligent
Apes that were nearly the dominant
species on Earth until humans and a
certain capricious Forest God pulled the
dirty trick on them they're better known
to most civilians as the legendary
Bigfoot or Sasquatch perhaps the most
famous Cryptid of all time or SCP 1337
The Hitchhiker an anomalous spectral
entity that manifests in the cars of
those who don't pick her up and performs
horrific acts of violence against them
she's eerily similar to Legends you can
find not only all over the us but the
entire world of ghostly hitchhikers
intruding into the cars of unwary
Travelers and scaring them half to death
or worse if you're unlucky another case
where myths and legends pointed thep
foundation in exactly the right
direction and of course there's SCP 136
the terrifying naked doll this was an
almost featureless children's doll found
inside an abandoned house but prolonged
time in its presence can make you the
victim of a warped Apparition that'll
drive you half mad with fear it's got
such a detrimental psychological effect
on people that the foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture
method during enhanced interrogation
sessions with captured members of rival
groups of interest and how did they find
it the foundation keeps track of
neighborhood rumors about haunted houses
with supposedly Supernatural inhabitants
clearly when it looks like it might
actually get results no myth or local
Legend is is too big or too small to
Warrant an investigation from the SCP
Foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less drunk Dr B
Renard set off with his team to Okanagan
Lake in search of what locals had
referred to as the legendary Ogo Pogo
we've all heard of the Loch Ness monster
the lake monster from Scotland that's
been turning heads for the better part
of a century and maybe related to two
other similar scps namely SCP 3934 and
SCP 5 533 but Ogopogo is Canada's answer
to good old Nessie while the Loch Ness
monster resembles a plaur the Ogopogo is
much more Serpentine with a long coiling
body covered in green scales its long
tail is said to be able to create Fierce
storms along the surface of the water
with its vicious whips killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray
too close the name Ogopogo is also a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
forwards as it does backwards and is
believed to to have originated in the
novelty song from the year
1924 however it's likely that the actual
Beast this somewhat Goofy name was given
to is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
Okanagan Valley Dr Renard very much
hoped this was the case of course he'd
explored the Legends heavily so much so
that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing the
schmeck and celix peoples the lake
dwelling monster was known as nit taka
which has been Loosely translated into
the sacred creature of the water the
water God and most menacing of all the
water demon the Beast was often
described in oral Traditions as being a
malicious Supernatural entity with great
power and ill intent towards those
trespassing on its territory Legend has
it that anyone who crosses Okanagan Lake
the supposed domain of the Ogopogo needs
to make a sacrifice to the monster in
order to ensure safe passage those who
refused to give this sacrifice the Beast
demanded would pay a heavy toll being
devoured or dragged down to a watery
grave never to be seen again and this
monster isn't just some old folk tale
either contemporary sightings have dated
back to
1873 with both settlers and First
Nations people alike spotting the
Sinister Ogopogo in the intervening
years Dr reard had poured through the
files on hundreds of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
group Green Piece moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in Okanagan Lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the FBI stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
Beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years later
there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
Okanogan Lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the Beast
underneath the water was more likely to
be a pair of logs bummer 2018 was an
exciting year for the yoogo with three
different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times
throughout the year Witnesses describe
the creature as being a giant snake
around 50 ft long which is consistent
with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the Beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python the non-anomalous
longest snake in the world so naturally
authority figures once again shot down
the validity of any claims that the
creature was actually real and out there
Dr reard found this almost funny they
didn't even need to suppress knowledge
of this creature if it really was out
there mainstream sources seemed to be
doing their job for them and keeping the
creature covered up he won was
determined though that he would be the
one to prove to his superiors that this
creature was indeed real and lurking in
Okanagan Lake he organized a number of
varied investigative missions from
actively trolling the lake itself to
conducting interviews with firsthand
witnesses as well as those who claim to
see no merit in their evidence and
testimony Dr reard noticed a strange
phenomenon the people who'd seen it
firsthand were as certain that it was
real as the doubters were that it was
fake even for typical Skeptics the
non-believer seemed shockingly Resolute
that there was really nothing down there
and the alleged photos and videos were
100% bogus early diagnostic tests into
the lake directly overseen by Dr Renard
seemed to point to a creature clearly
being down there he found the direct
testimony both compelling and consistent
with what he and his team were catching
glimpses of so why were people so
adamant that nothing was down there it
was almost like the yoogo really was as
mythical as the first Nations Legend
said and it was casting a spell on all
the non-believers that's when it hit Dr
Renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with Cognito
hazardous Powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
sought up close would actually believe
that the creature was real anyone who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity no nobody except those who
saw it directly would ever believe that
it existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous Hunter Dr rard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his Mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation SCP 1933 before
sending it back to his supervisors they
wrote back saying that they didn't feel
as though there was enough of a basis
and evidence to deem this entry Worthy
of inclusion if Dr Renard wanted to have
his so-called Ogopogo dignified with
entry into the SCP Foundation archives
he needed to back it up properly this
presented a problem to Dr Renard how
could he provide documentation and
evidence for a creature that had the
defining anomalous power of making all
of its own documentation and evidence
seem phony he was caught between a rock
and a hard place with only one solution
create the most undeniably highquality
evidence of the creatures that the world
had ever seen not long after that his
superiors at the SCP Foundation would
receive a video file from Dr reard
according to the notes on his report he
set up a track using an ALK carcass to
lure the creature out of the water and
capture HD video of its feeding when the
senior researchers gathered around to
watch the video they were astounded an
animatronic a cheap rubber suit around a
somewhat janky robot like something
you'd see at a theme park how much had
Dr rard spent on this absurd farce did
he think it was funny despite Dr
Renard's protests he was reprimanded
severely for this waste of foundation
resources the object class on his 1933
file was switched to explained meaning a
rational nonanomalous explanation for
The observed phenomenon had been found
discrediting it and the 1933 slot was
instead filled with a strange fat man
dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are all Irish Cream the ultimate
humiliation Dr Renard was left with
nothing and we joined him once again
where we started with Dr Renard standing
on the ledge of Okanagan Lake staring
hatefully into the water as something
seemed to move underneath if Dr rard
screamed that night there was nobody
there to hear it his remains were
dredged out of the lake the next day His
official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating
accident though the boat in question was
never found reports that his corpse was
found half eaten have mostly been
dismissed as rumors after all there is
no such thing as the Ogo Pogo the divers
screams A Silent Scream as the giant
Squid's beak digs into his skin its many
grasping tentacles grabbing him and
holding him in place nearby his fellow
divers are driven half mad with Terror
as they see mysterious figures floating
towards them through the MC and strange
Russian voices speaking in their heads
nobody can help them they're down too
deep too consumed by the darkness and
the pressure of the sea they're now at
the mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage what followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 as United States citizens
feared they were teetering on the brink
of nuclear war in July of 1968 the
Soviet Union the United Kingdom and the
United States came together to sign the
treaty on the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater water
wreckage of a Soviet submarine that sank
in March of 1968 and came into the
custody of the SCP Foundation in 1999
the submarine a version of the Charlie 2
class was deployed under unusual
circumstances which attracted the
attention of the United States
government in an attempt to learn more
about the submarine the US government
launched project redacted which
attempted to recover the vessel from the
ocean in the early 1970s they managed to
recover a few pieces of the vessel
though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible euklid or
ker class anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a Mann Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described in incident report
1741a divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be it
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fix it on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerge from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation too and began to panic
some checked their nitrogen levels
believing it to be some sort of nitrogen
Narcosis While others pointed out that
they couldn't all be suffering from
nitrogen Narcosis at the same time the
unknown voice continued speaking saying
help me it is getting hard to breathe
the divers debated what to do next
questioning whether what they were
seeing was was even real when all at
once the humanoid figure vanished from
sight the divers attempted to shake off
the startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a 5 m
long squid swimming around the wreckage
its presence startled the divers at
first particularly those closest to the
animal but the others encouraged them to
ignore it citing the fact that there are
no records of these squid attacking
humans so they did continuing their work
as the squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of of approximately 250 M
starting around the center of the
submarine the pressure in this area is
much greater than it should be given the
depth of the waters there this unusually
high pressure makes sonar analysis
extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and US
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basti was patrolling the area
around SCP 741 when its sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching SCP 741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basti attempted to reach the contact via
sonab Bui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an undersea missile launch and
basti responded with the utmost urgency
the ship broke away from its original
area and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds after the
basti launched its torpedo missiles of
an unidentified configuration were seen
breaking the water flying at a height of
1.8 m and a velocity of .92 Mach the
missiles did not emit any detectable
radar nor did they respond to any launch
chaff or flares from the basti both of
the missiles were engaged by bti's 3K N5
Kinsel surfac to- aair missiles and ctan
point defense systems and were destroyed
at 1800 M and 210 M from Impact
respectively after the missiles were
neutralized the Hostile vessel could be
heard engaging in evasive maneuvers at
this point the there were four closely
spaced explosions and the sound of a
submarine disintegrating the identity of
the attacker as well as its intention
toward SCP 741 have not yet been
determined the incident resulted in the
foundation research team suggesting an
expansion of the acoustic sensor net as
well as additional Patrol and defense
assets placed in the area additionally
they advised an acquisition of undersea
retaliatory capability the incident was
classified incident 1741 C the our
recordings from the scps bisti during
incident 1741 DC were taken for further
analysis by the research team the
in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remained protected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years we've seen
those reports project redacted now we
know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crew Men We buried Just
Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in this thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at v preparent as spies wind
up owing each other favors after a while
and they denied it vehemently not your
usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redacted doctor
do you have any idea what it takes to
make a bioweapons researcher sick now
that wasn't what really bugged me though
what really kept me awake at night was
the KGB file that fell into our hands
they mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control
they wanted to lose it whatever it was
or maybe fob it off onto the US of
course that all came to light right
before the Iron Curtain fell and given
the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loan and you
half the Pacific Fleet in all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets as CP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea violent
chaos unfolds across the shoreline huge
fleshy tendrils Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant harpoons
made of bone whiz across the beach
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
droves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million years be able
to to guess its source on April 10th
2010 something strange began to happen
in the three Portlands now the anomalous
extradimensional city state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the aisle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice that something
was happening but for some unknown
reason sailboats and motorboats were
beginning to vanish from the city The
Disappearance occurred overnight when
there was no one around to witness them
but slowly the citizens began to notice
that their friends and family members
were going out in their watercrafts and
never returning home by April 15th the
civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned fearing the worst on April
16th their worst fears were confirmed
when two local ghosts Anar Ahmed and
Greg Moore went for a nighttime stroll
along the harbor they heard a sudden
commotion and Rush to the scene of the
disturbance they arrived just in time to
see a living individual being dragged
into the watery depths by a large
veinlike tendril Ahmed asked Greg to
wait on land while he ventured out into
the water to look for the victim
unfortunately ammed never came back and
Greg took his story to the three
Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local maned
and clam populace to migrate the FBI
unusual incidence unit mounted a formal
investigation on the morning of of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April first
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11:19 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
mass masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the Shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert ISAT
a noted member of the Church of to the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach ISAT a city security Gollum
interfered sadly though the gollum put
up a valiant fight the anomaly was able
to destroy it by Falling onto it again
and again until the Golem was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the GRL was in the middle of a
busy brunch service at the sight of the
invading watercraft the GRL set down his
piture of bottomless mimosas wiped his
hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual wield swords from underneath
the counter he kept them there in case
someone attempted to dine and dash but
he figured they would do just fine
against a blood drinking tug boat while
the GRL kept the tugboat busy uiu forces
were able to break through the barricade
of boats for a brief period of time
allowing more security Golems to enter
the area as well as allowing more
citizens to escape unfortunately this
little victory was shortlived as further
unforeseen Horrors drudged themselves up
from the deep the reanimated corpses of
various species native to the harbor
began to crawl out of the water
surrounding the GRL and allowing the
tugboat to escape the fight as it made
its way back to the harbor every boat it
passed attempted to toss bodies onto the
tugboat covering it in fresh blood
slowly but surely the damage to the
tugboat began to repair itself once the
boat had regained its strength it set
its sights on a previously untouched
cargo ship an observing uiu officer
determined that the boat was somehow
attempting to convert the cargo ship to
transform it into another one of its
fleshy allies but before the
transformation could take place a cargo
crate broke open spilling over 1,000
hard tack crackers suddenly the tugboat
stopped everything that it was doing it
took one tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
while the tugboat was distracted with
its task a citizen offered the uiu use
of their rare Metals Cannonball
collection in the fight to apprehend the
aggressive boat one particular
Cannonball made from electrum was able
to puncture the hole of one of the
infected ships rendering it motionless
they were elated to have found a weapon
that worked against these boats while
the tugboat continued to count the
remaining towns people gathered all of
the electrum they could find and began
to fight back against the boats one by
one the boats sank and all the while the
tugboat continued to count in the
meantime uiu officers managed to free
the GRL from his zombie attackers they
presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the guru barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the GRL
then threw the tugboat out of the water
and continued The Savage beating before
preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat kened through the air colliding
with a portal that had transported it to
the aisle of Portland luckily this
portal could only be unlocked via a
high-speed impact from a water-based
vehicle speaking of luck an SCP
Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the GRL and and in its
incapacitated state it was transported
to a nearby Foundation site there it was
contained and given the designation of
SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker class Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a constant state
of rust and degr ation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
cations The Entity does not only use the
absorb blood to improve its appearance
but is also capable of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tendrils spotted
in the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP
6426 C masses of reanimated tissue that
the boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP 6426 uses its tendrils
to grab prey and drag them towards
itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow hard scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
take in by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 these instances are used to the
entity's advantage helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well
as providing an additional line of
defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use SCP 6426 daa to
convert the vehicle into an instance of
SCP 6426 DB these converted boats are
similar to SCP 6426 and are able to
function on their own however they are
unable to produce their own I stocks or
canons unable to create SCP 6426 daa
instances and do not appear to be as
intelligent as their creator in the
early days of its containment the exact
nature of the anomaly's intelligence was
the subject of debate amongst the
research staff however on one specific
occasion the foundation was able to
establish a line of direct communication
with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that SCP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher
sjad Williamson in spite of his protests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks salans yes
right
how Dr Williamson's first question
concerned SCP 6426 apparent intended
victim back in three Portlands Albert
ISAT SCP 6426 responded Albert his first
name is really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless Man
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me he was leading a search
party of those barbaric naop files
intending to gut me like a seal what do
you mean people people like you Dr
Williamson inquired freethinkers of
course people who are unafraid to break
from the mold to carve their own path in
life instead of following the
predetermined route set by that ignorant
check valve the church is buil upon a
foundation of lies no one's really a
petty officer on this ship we're all
just cabin boys stumbling around in the
dark as we follow the commands of an
offhand
coob
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the port hole and he'll
squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and
how you arrived there well after I got
the B swans off my trail I found a cave
to hide in I was forced to hide in yes
forced to hide deep in the cave which
turned out to be a tunnel surprisingly
the tunnel led to some Coastal Community
where I took Refuge licking my wounds in
the safety of the depths as those
zealots stocked the surface I spent my
time preparing Gathering the strength
necessary to face them once more until I
was ambushed assaulted within my Hideout
by a b swine I fought for my life as I
was forced out into the open and
descended upon by a manner of monsters
and freaks of this orchestrated by that
scumbag eard I was beaten within an inch
of my life before I'm not quite sure
what happened after that I believe I was
knocked unconscious you'll have to
Illuminate Me on how I came to be in
your custody at this point the interview
began to Veer in an odd Direction the
boat Express confusion about the nature
of Williamson's questions specifically
how little they related to the subject
of sharks and punching them it was at
this point that the site director sought
guidance from the multi Department a
researcher there informed Williamson
about the confusion SCP 6426 had
mistaken the SCP Foundation for another
organization the shark punching Center
Dr Williamson resumed the interview
prepared to play along and keep the boat
comfortable unfortunately Williamson was
a terrible liar yes we are the shark
punching Center we will determine if you
are a suitable candidate to carry out
the mission to search punch and contain
sh I mean salti this verbal misstep
caused SCP 6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently SC CP 6426 is kept in a 39 MX
39 MX 50 m containment chamber beneath
the chamber there is an artificial lava
tube the tugboat has a naval Ram through
its Hull and engine holding it in place
this Ram is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly immobile if the ram
is ever removed or damaged some a
failsafe system will activate releasing
100 hardtack crackers and two pieces of
electrum into the containment chamber
this is intended to keep the tugboat
occupied until the naval Rod can be
replaced if for some reason the naval
Rod fails and the boat runs out of heart
attack to count while there will be
nowhere on water or land that we can
hide it was just a job you were meant to
be mopping floors and cleaning toilets
at the Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage and you
were happy about it grateful for any
kind of employment you didn't even know
that the company signing your checks was
the SCP Foundation an organization
dedicated to securing and containing
anomalies and protecting Humanity from
their negative effects at any cost and
today you're going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be the Johnston
labs and pharmaceuticals Research Center
isn't actually a research center at all
it's a foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly SCP
3280 but again you're just the janitor
it's not like they would bother telling
you what's being contained here if it
breaks out you won't even know what's
killing you until it's too late it
begins like most classic horror stories
on a dark and stormy night you're
mopping up a silent hallway whistling a
little tune to yourself when rain starts
hammering down on the window next to you
not long after you see a bolt of
lightning split the distant Sky followed
by an immense Thunder crack soon after
you hear screaming and panicking From
Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens you think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing Containment Breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you the broom closet the alarm
blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time you can't
help but wonder why isn't anybody coming
to help us after for a while the only
thing you can hear is the rain and the
distant Thunder it's been hours you've
only managed to Stave off dehydration by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now's your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bod stes everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr coone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific scream
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and push on when you
enter the security room you see that the
head security officer Nicholls is
already dead his body has been cut open
from neck to groin gutted the anomaly
whatever it is has already been here you
access the computer terminal and open
the file for SCP
3280 you're warned that as janitorial
staff you have level zero clearance and
as a result information will be omitted
from the files you access it doesn't
matter you press on and open up the file
both the object class and the
description have been redacted you can
only see the special containment
procedures they dictate that 3280 is to
remain contained at the Johnston labs
and pharmaceuticals Research Center
until long-term containment procedures
can be drawn up if the entity ever
reaches Beyond subl 2 the facility
enters full lockdown mode not even
information is allowed in or out of the
facility as this could result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario in other
words nobody is coming to save you the
only other information on the page is a
picture of a lightning storm much like
the one you find yourself in right now
lightning flashes in the hall you Dart
around paranoid knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere all you can hear now
is the quiet drip drip drip of blood
coming from the body of security officer
Nicholls whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around Nicholls
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nicholls was the kind of
guy who'd write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level two
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift noose attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr Emanuel
stumbling down a dark Corridor his
movements are oddly listless like he's
in a trance suddenly there's another
flash of lightning and a crack of
thunder Dr Emanuel clutches his gut in
pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols and the special
containment procedures now they're
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from sublevel
2 and see another corpse lying in the
corner he's wearing an orange jumpsuit
d-class no idea why he was down there
there the only other notable thing in
the basement was a burst pipe leaking
and spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically underwater the
only evidence of the massacre that must
have taken place are the fragments of
clothing floating on the surface of the
water that and the fleshy pink slurry
forming at the bottom of the windows it
reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories you close your
eyes and try to Center yourself it's
violent chaos looking at more of it
isn't getting you anywhere instead you
put those new level two security access
credentials to good use and hop back
onto the file for SCP 3280 you think to
yourself there has to be something I can
use on here but even as you wait for the
file to load some part of you knows that
time is running out for you perhaps it's
the stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drink R but you're feeling the
pressures start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for SCP 3280 is now
Declassified uid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now EXP explain that
every week a new member of d-class
personnel is to be deposited into the
entity's layer in sublevel 2 through
Subterranean access point gamma the
d-class or more accurately the
sacrifices are to be told lies about why
exactly they need to descend to the
lowest point in the facility they're
even given a working flashlight and a
defensive night stick to create the
illusion that the foundation expects
them to ever return from the depths
little do they know they also have a
tiny transmitter sewn into their
jumpsuit this broadcasts a frequency
that will attract an eager SCP 3280 to
the d-class location like a dinner bell
only it can hear the file specifies that
SCP 3280 always prefers live prey well
at least that explains the dead d-class
in sublevel 2 you think hoping that it
will somehow overwhelm the dizziness
you're feeling or the nagging pain in
your gut you read on somehow the file's
tone becomes even more severe it says
that failure to maintain the containment
of SCP 3280 will not only trigger a
lockdown it will always call in the
intervention of two different mobile
task forces MTF Iota 12 the silencers
and to 4 also known as water water
everywhere if 12 hours pass from the
point of initial Containment Breach and
the 05 Council hasn't been given the all
clear signal by one of these teams
preparation Begins for an imminent XK
Class end of the Worlds scenario just
reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat end of the world what on Earth is
this creature finally you reach the
description you get to find out what
this horrifying entity actually is but
the last thing you expect is the first
sentence in the file to read SCP 3280 is
a Sapient entity composed of a fluid
physically identical to water capable of
traveling roughly 2 and 1/2 km per hour
it's water it's literally a living
thinking blob of water as you read on
the concerning details pile up any water
that the anomalous SCP 3280 water
touches it integrates it into its own
Mass but anytime water is separated from
this Mass it remains anomalous and
continues to act independently when the
creature was first discovered it was a
mere 66.4 l in volume now it's around
2500 the water infected by SCP 3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in a
defensive manner SCP 3280 will actively
seek out human prey and when it finds
them it forces its mass into any
available body orifice including the
victim's pores this can happen in such a
subtle manner that you may not even
notice yourself being infiltrated but
below this the file has a list of
symptoms for those experiencing 30280
infiltration loss of motor control
weakening of the m I reflex visual
hallucinations and abdominal pain as you
read the words your stomach gives
another painful churn almost like
something is moving around inside of you
it's all coming together you read on the
file states that SCP 3280 is so
difficult to contain because it exhibits
claustrophobic Tendencies anytime it's
placed inside a container whether
organic or inorganic it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at
over 2 55 mph if the water is inside a
human it may literally explode out of
them killing them in the process your
jittering eyes turned to the gutted body
of security officer Nicholls it all
makes sense now everything is becoming
clearer as the pain in your stomach
builds in its intensity the file goes on
to say that if SCP 3280 escapes sublevel
2 it may be impossible to contain again
if 3280 ever escaped the site proper it
would would indeed cause an XK Class end
of the world scenario to unfold as 3280
merged with our water cycle and
destroyed all of Humanity on a global
scale it would become truly impossible
for anyone to escape you can't read
anymore the pain in your stomach is
unbearable you jerk from your seat and
stumble out into the Hall doubled over
in agony you can feel it pulsing in
there fighting its way out it must have
gotten in through the filthy mop water
you were drinking you didn't even know
it but your fate has been sealed for
hours you've been a dead man walking the
hum of pain builds in your ears and
renders you almost death all you can
hear is the pattern of rain and distant
Thunder you collapse against the glass
feeling the coolness of it against the
skin of your face and in that moment you
see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse Direction they're
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you SCP 3280 has escaped it's out there
and it's going to drown the entire world
as you collapse to your knees and
prepare to be torn apart from the inside
your final thought is that at least you
won't be alive to see it Commander
McGrath one of the most influential
members of mobile task force alpha 1
better known as the red right hand had
been summoned by his Masters for one of
the most important missions of of his
life it was so Above Top Secret even he
would likely need to undergo amnestic
treatment once he'd seen the job through
it comes with a territory when you're
dealing with SCP
006 the red right hand is no ordinary
mobile taskforce either they were the
personal enforcers of the 05 Council the
13 most powerful members of the SCP
Foundation and by extension some of the
most powerful human beings on Earth
Commander grath stood before the
assembled Council trying to suppress the
Tremors of fear and awe running through
him he'd gone toe-to-toe with SCP 076
Abel one of the finest humanoid Warriors
ever known during one of his many
containment breaches he led strike
forces after a fleeing SCP 682 the heart
to destroy reptile after it escaped its
acid tank and began charging towards the
nearest populated area intent on causing
Mass death he'd personally taken out
more people than you've probably ever
met all at the behest of his foundation
superiors and yet standing right here
before them he couldn't help feel a
twinge of deep Terror it was like
staring right into the face of God and
waiting for it to Blink with his
well-honed military observation skills
he noted that
were something special he wasn't given
any more information than this McGrath
we need you to lead an elite team to a
Sten in Russia on the double procedure
006 is now in effect you know what to do
McGrath nodded he'd been prepared for
this day his predecessor Commander
Richards had only needed to enact
procedure 006 once in his long and
storyed career with the red right hand
it was truly a once-in-a-lifetime
assignment and now the torch had been
passed to him the only question was
whether he'd be up to the task but
McGrath didn't have time to ponder on
this question time was of the essence
first he needed to assemble a team small
but focused loyal men who'd Keep Their
Heads down complete the mission and take
the Forbidden Knowledge no further than
the bounds of said Mission McGrath
selected three operatives Bennett dagio
and Stewart all of whom had proven
valuable assets in Prior missions they
would be the ones to accompany him on
this most valuable and secretive of
directives procedure
006 but before they could execute the
mission itself they needed to be trained
briefed and fitted with the proper
equipment for Mission this sensitive and
dealing with an anomaly as deadly as SCP
006 they needed to wear modified class 6
B and C suits these are the ultimate
total exclusion hazmat suits designed
specifically by the SCP Foundation they
offered such a degree of protection that
they made Regular hazmat suits look like
bikinis Commander McGrath actually knew
very little about SCP 006 and how it
worked like many of the more top secret
anomalies contained by the foundation
only the 05 Council understood the full
scope of it everyone below them were
only told the specific fragments of
information they needed to do their job
after all filling your head with the
wrong kinds of knowledge can get your
memory wiped or worse at the SCP
Foundation
SCP 006 as far as Commander McGrath knew
was the more traditional kind of toxic
he'd been briefed using the SCP 006b
info pack a heavily redacted description
of SCP
006 safe class liquid and nature but one
of the most toxic substances known to
man it made Mercury and uranium look
like a glass of mineral water and more
dangerous still if someone came into
contact with even the tiniest quantity
of SCP 006 is liquids they would not
only be marked for certain death they
would also become a vector for
transmission a veritable plague rat a
walking danger to all mankind that's why
the class 6 BNC suits needed to be
tested McGrath Bennett dagio and Stewart
suited up in a secure foundation
training facility and fully submerged
themselves in a training pool this was
how they made sure that there were no
vulnerabilities in the suits if any
bubbles were ated it meant there was a
leak and if there was a leak then the
person wearing the defective suit was as
good as dead when they reached the real
006 lucky for them no leaks they were
ready to proceed to the next stage of
the mission making their way to arren
Russia where SCP 006 was contained the
pressure was on with the council growing
more impatient by the moment so they
needed to make the journey immediately
every minute counted and Commander grath
was painfully aware of the time slipping
away though he couldn't possibly fathom
why they need a toxic chemical like this
with such urgency they made their
journey in a covert cargo plane it was
beyond important to keep all Foundation
activity around SCP 006 Under Wraps a
number of groups of Interest cells were
active in the area including the Church
of the broken God and the Serpent's hand
and if ever the dreaded chaos Insurgency
CAU wind of SCP 00 6's existence and
triangulated its location the damage it
could do would be unprecedented that's
why nobody but the 05 council could
truly be trusted with this almost sacred
knowledge when they touched down in
estren they met with a foundation
Courier who would take them on the final
leg of their Journey to the foundation
site roughly 60 km west of the Town
McGrath and his team had no idea what
they were headed towards or the insane
history of the land they traversed all
because of SCP 06 the foundation had
first become aware of the anomaly back
during the 19th century but were unable
to gain control of it until 1991 due to
it being fiercely guarded by A
procession of territorial Russian rulers
the blood of hundreds of thousands had
been spilled on this land in the
historic Wars and conflicts over SCP
006 so many had wasted their entire
lives unsuccessfully trying to find it
during the several hour car trip to the
site Commander McGrath had no idea of
the true value of the anomaly he and his
small team were heading towards but he
would in time though an innocent would
have to die first The Courier dropped
the four operatives off outside an
abandoned chemical plant in the sticks
far from what anyone would call
civilization it was the kind of
industrial Decay you could expect in the
bad lands of rural Russia a huge complex
weathered and broken by time but what
the untrained Observer wouldn't realize
is that the plant was actually full of
heavily trained and even more heavily
armed Foundation security personnel as
McGrath's team approached the building
they had no less than eight sniper
rifles pointed at them from various
Vantage points within the plant just to
be safe the foundation couldn't afford
to take any chances with SCP
006 they arrived at the gate and
provided their clearance credentials
they were envoys here on behalf of the
05 Council themselves and if they
weren't allowed to complete their
Mission then the 006 Personnel would
have the death of a council member on
their hands with that the team was given
a free pass into the site under close
observation anyone seeking to interface
SCP 006 was forced to do so under almost
microscopic scrutiny even when inside
the building McGrath and his men needed
to pass multiple secure checkpoints
throughout the Halls each time restating
their security credentials eventually
they reached a different section of the
building for boating anomalous hallways
gave way to what seemed like a mix of a
garden and a jungle but the plants were
different the trees the shrubs even the
weeds were unlike anything members of
the team had ever seen before it was
like stepping into an alien world or
perhaps this world but as it was a few
million years prior it was terrifying
and wondrous they suited up in their
class 6 BNC suits fearing Airborne
contaminant from SCP 006 before
proceeding further they walk through
this new Jungle being watched at every
turn by security cameras and Personnel
posted throughout this overgrown portion
of the facility it didn't take long for
them to reach their destination the
legendary SCP
006 a small natural spring jutting out
of a rock surrounded by Rich Emerald
grass it looked more like a nice place
to have a picnic than a dangerous and
highly secretive anomaly but McGrath
wasn't paid to question things only to
carry out procedure
006 the only object they had with them
was the quad sealant container an ultra
secure liquid containment unit
specifically designed for safely
transporting samples of SCP 006s water
between sights the team members
descended into the spring and began
filling up the container it was
nerve-wracking knowing the stakes of
their mission and knowing that they were
submerged in such a deadly substance but
they had a job to do and they were going
to do it come hell or high water they
filled the containment unit but sadly
for McGrath and his team the mission
wouldn't be entirely without casualty a
single bubble Rose from the leg of
Stuart's suit he was a good MTF
operative but the youngest and least
experienced member of the team his suit
must have somehow been damaged during
Transit and now he was compromised he
shared a haunting glance with McGrath
and his fellow team members knowing that
his part of the mission and his life was
about to come to a Swift and violent end
alarms rang out across the facility a
huge team of armed operatives all
wearing class 6 BNC suits charged into
the room Stuart was grabbed and
manhandled out of the 06 spring while
his fellow team members sealed the
containment unit and continued their
mission there was no time to stop rest
or mourn completing the mission was the
absolute priority if McGrath understood
the protocol as well as he thought he
did Stuart would be dragged into a
secure room by the sight staff and
locked in with a blast door he would
look down and notice the floor below him
was a metal grate caked with Ash his
last thoughts as the incinerator
launches its Flames into action would
strangely be the fact that he was
feeling the healthiest he'd been in
years but that wouldn't stop the sudden
furnace around him from decimating his
body and leaving little more than Ash
and charred bones over a decade of loyal
MTF service ended in an in instant
Stewart would have been terminated
according to orders from the top it was
all that could be done for those
afflicted by a SCP 006 a mercy really if
they were to be believed McGrath and his
team soldiered on after retrieving the
sample they were hurried back into their
Inception point one of the many
classified bases occupied by the 05
council members while dagio and Bennett
were ushered off to be given amnestic
treatment McGrath would personally get
to see the containment unit and its
Precious Cargo make the final leg of the
journey he was going to be granted
access
25-2 the person this had all been in
service of Commander McGrath approached
the secure quarters of the council
member escorted by a bevy of heavily
armed security Personnel the doors open
and he saw her there
s of her ancient face she didn't look
like one of the most powerful people in
the world she looked like one of the
most feeble her eyes lit up when McGrath
entered the room holding the containment
unit she beckoned him closer until he
was close enough for her to take the
containment unit from him with scarred
Trembling Hands McGrath watched in
horror as she disengaged the lid and
swigged down the entirety of its
contents but wasn't the water toxic he
thought McGrath had been fed the same
lie as everybody else the Foundation
didn't keep 006 such a well-guarded
secret because it was capable of
bringing death quite the opposite in
fact all Commander McGrath could do was
stare a struck as the years seemed to
fall from 0 5-2 face decades and decades
and decades scars faded wrinkles
disappeared little by little 0 5-2 began
to sit and then stand by the time she
was straightening her clothes she looked
like a healthy woman in her mid-40s it
was a complete and total transformation
the liquid of SCP 006 has a plethora of
benefits to human subjects the ability
to regenerate damaged DNA by heightened
excitement of cellular duplication and
producing a frightening increase in the
effectiveness of the human immune system
even upon testing the liquid on animal
subjects hostile bacteria and viral
agents were destroyed immediately
members of the 05 Council are experts at
cheating death and SCP 006 is just
another Ace hidden up their sleeve in
the endless battle against the reaper a
secret so well guarded that they're
willing to terminate even their most
loyal servants to keep it safe after all
if everyone knew about it everyone would
want it and the 05 Council are very
invested in exclusivity never normally
one to rise above his station Commander
McGrath couldn't help blur out but if it
was all Li private Stewart is perfectly
alive all smoke mirrors you see and like
everyone who works a 006 mission he
won't remember a thing good work
Commander McGrath 052 now in perfect
health replied now return to your post
after a visit to our boys and amnestics
there's still plenty to be done and we
can't afford to dilly-dally after all
you're not getting any younger you're on
a road trip the kind that stretches over
days on end and you need to make
multiple stops along the way to refuel
the car and yourself the last time you
were remember stopping to get more gas
and a bite to eat was back in Wyoming
and now you're in the heart of Montana
thankfully like an oasis in the desert
you see the town of clear water off in
the distance it's a vibrant welcoming
little place a perfect slice of classic
small town Americana you took a similar
trip last year and vaguely remember
stopping at Clear Water that time too
and you're glad to be back in particular
you remember the old Prairie Diner a
folksy little place with the most
delicious huckleberry pie you ever
tasted perhaps it's about time for you
to give it another try you fill up your
tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from the weight staff to the cashier to
the cooks have all been replaced you try
your best not to think about it after
all businesses are allowed to replace
their staff but the longer you sit in
the diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not going crazy when the waiter passes
by you compliment the food and mention
you ate here last year too you asked the
unfamiliar waiter if they had worked
here back then they confirm that yes
they've always worked here and so has
everybody else the diner is a family
business you leave town not too long
after that feeling vaguely unsettled and
as a voice on the radio warns about the
the incoming rain you tell yourself that
you never want to return to the town of
Clearwater Montana as you leave the
memory of the Town seems to fade from
your mind in real time but little do you
know the people of clear water will
never be able to leave ever it's because
something horrifying will happen in
Clear Water every single year and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as
SCP
3300 this annual anomalous event is
Clearwater's own local current always
occurring around mid June while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
SCP 3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a malstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in Clear Water remains
in Clear Water and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed
whenever the foundation has tried to
send Personnel or equipment into clear
water during SCP 3300 one of two things
has happened in the more favorable
scenarios those attempting to enter
clear water have simply appeared on the
other side of the city limits in the
less positive instances personnel and
Equipment have been lost forever within
there is no stopping or even
understanding as CP 3300 according to
Foundation records clear water has been
around at least as long as the found
Foundation itself perhaps even longer
clear water has been able to undergo its
yearly nightmare without intrusion due
to a unique Cognito hazardous effect
which creates a kind of mental block
around memories of the town for
Outsiders you won't forget clear water
per se but you will find it increasingly
hard to focus on like something you can
only ever see out of the corner of your
eye there is no saving the people of
clear water the horror will play out
again and again and again again the
foundation has no firsthand knowledge of
what happens in Clear Water during those
horrifying 18 days but one account they
have hints at a terrifying possibility
during an Excursion into clearw the
foundation managed to collect a diary
belonging to a woman named Margaret Lane
to the best of our knowledge Margaret
Lane no longer exists but if the
contents of her diary aren't to be
believed then what goes on in Clear
Water during SCP 3300 is far worse than
we ever imagine imaged Margaret first
started her diary not long before SCP
3300s 1995 iteration began she was in
the middle of a tumultuous time in her
life freshly clean from alcohol and drug
addiction forced to live with her
antagonistic mother and having peculiar
and distressing dreams in the first
Dream Margaret recorded she was someone
else a woman living in a small Hut
perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedan her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended Margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was coming it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
SCP 3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of the place to Margaret life
carried on she continued to stay clean
resisting the offers of her old dealer
though her relationship with her mother
remained Frosty the rain started to get
worse as voices on the radio insisted
that conditions would continue to become
more severe over the next few days they
tried their best to maintain normality
Margaret invited some friends Jared Sam
Mike and Isabelle to come over and play
D and D at her place that was when all
hell broke loose while the group role
played there was a furious banging at
the door like whoever was knocking was
trying to bash the door down when
Margaret's mom opened the door to
investigate the commotion she saw that
an entire family was standing there a
father a mother and two young children
the father immediately began furiously
asking why all these strangers were in
his house when Margaret's mother tried
to tell him that this wasn't his house
he became increasingly agitated and
walked straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
Str strength Margaret's mom ran in with
a golf club and struck the mysterious
man in the chest there was a nasty Splat
but he didn't seem to react the golf
club was just embedded in his chest
having broken the skin and sunken in but
there was no blood just dripping water
the father then pulled the golf club out
of his chest and began beating
Margaret's mother to death with it all
while repeating my house again and again
while his wife and children watched with
broad Sunny smile miles in the rain
somehow Margaret knew that her mother
was beyond saving and that there was no
way of defeating these things in a
physical confrontation all they could do
was run out to Jared's van with the rest
of the group and hight tail it to the
police station but when they arrived at
the station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
and done they drove for what seemed like
hours on end as the rain and the howling
wind persisted Jared had been injured
during the fight with the strange family
and his health deteriorated further as
the drive stretched on they should have
left the town of clear water a long time
ago but it seemed like they were nowhere
it wasn't long before Jared was lying
dead in the back of the van and now
there were only four of them left they
kept driving afraid grieving hungry and
tired and Market took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
Cascade of hot steam after that Margaret
and the others left the vehicle and
refused to get back inside nothing was
making sense it was like something out
of a nightmare as they walked the rain
hammer down upon them they couldn't have
been walking for more than a mile when
they crashed into something it was a
sign welcome to Clear Water it was like
that the town itself had drawn them back
Mike refused to return to the town of
his own free will and began walking in
the other direction moments later he was
walking back towards them in silence
though he never intended to SCP 3300 had
distorted his path and brought him back
it was clear that Mike was shaken to the
core by the experience but they had to
to press on they would head to the
grocery store for food and then to a
sporting goods store where they could
hopefully grab some guns to fight the
violent altered people who'd somehow
appeared with the rain but things didn't
go to plan or what little plan there
even was Mike shot himself on the first
night at Dirk Sporting Goods leaving
only Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive
perhaps one of the most terrifying
details of Mike's death was the fact he
didn't even bleed instead the gaping
exit wound in the back of his head was
just full of water water was all that
seemed to be left of them Sam seemingly
driven to the Edge by the sight of
Mike's death grabbed a hunting knife to
perform an experiment she'd cut into her
own skin and was horrified to see only
water dripping out they'd all been
changed and they didn't know why that's
when the survivors noticed something
else there were people standing outside
in the rain hundreds of them not a
single one they could recognize all new
people waiting Sam said only one word
outside before walking out of the
hunting goods store and disappearing
into the crowd in the rain never to be
seen Again Margaret mused that perhaps
in the end she had the right idea to be
taken killed erased or change would be
inevitable in the final entry in
Margaret's diary dreams blend with
reality as her mind finally gives out
from the terror she realizes in her
final moments that there is no way out
there is no Escape there is only water
water is eternal the rain is eternal all
will be changed and given the fact that
no trace of Margaret was ever found save
for her diary all her fears turned out
to be right she was taken and replaced
by SCP 3300 just as will inevitably
happen to all the current citizens of
clear water the next time SCP 3300 rolls
around it will be as inevitable and as
indifferent to those it affects as
tomorrow's sunrise
you cannot change the rain but believe
us in Clearwater Montana the rain can
change you now check out SCP 2000 deos
exmachina and SCP 3001 red reality for
more anomalies that'll make you see the
world a little differently